GOOD AFTERNOON IN RESPONSE TO
THE CALL THAT NINETEEN
EMERGENCY AND TO PROTECT THE
PUBLIC LEGISLATORS EMPLOYEES WE
MUST LIMIT NONESSENTIAL
GATHERINGS AND HERE TO SOCIAL
DISTANCING AND FACE COVERING
GUIDELINES. THANK YOU PLANTS
WITH THOSE OR A SET HAS MADE.
ADJUSTMENTS NORTH IN ORDER AND
THAT THE INTO TO HAVE A TO
LEGISLATIVE. ROLLING COMMITTEE
HEARINGS HERE IN THE CAPITAL
WITH SOME OF OUR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. IS BEING REMOTELY
MEMBER TENDING REMOTELY TODAY
IS SENATORS. SENATE HAVE A
STAFF PERSON IT'S IN YOUR
OFFICE PLEASE IDENTIFY THAT
STAFFORD THIS TIME. I SEE
SENATOR SENATOR STERN DID MAKE
AN APPEARANCE A MOMENT AGO I'M
SURE HE WILL RETURN WILL COME
BACK TO SENATORS STERN- TO
ALLOW PUBLIC ACCESS WITH MEN
MEMBERS OF PUBLIC TO TWO
HEARING ROOMS TO THE EXTENT OF
SOCIAL DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS
ALLOW WILL BE USNG A
TELECONFERENCE OR WAS FOR THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WHO WAS TESTIFYING
TODAY WELL INDIVIDUALS WISHING
TO PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT THE
PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE NUMBER
AND ACCESS CODE IS POSTED ARE
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. IT WILL BE
DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN THE
WHOLE ANNOUNCE IT NOW. TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS. EIGHT
FOUR FOUR TWO NINE ONE FOUR ONE
EIGHT FIVE. AND THE- ACCESS
CODE IS. THREE TWO SIX SIX ONE
EIGHT EIGHT FOR DETAILED
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE
TELECONFERENCES TO WORKS PLEASE
pWEBSITE WILL MOVE PUBLIC
COMMENT YOU'LL BE PROMPTED BY
MODERATOR DAHLE ONE THEN ZERO
FOR SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION PRESS%
THIS ONLY ONE TIME AND WAIT
PATIENTLY FOR AN OPERATOR TO
ASSIGN YOU A LINE NUMBER THERE
MAY BE A SHORT WAIT. WHAT YOU
RECEIVE YOUR LINE NUMBER YOU'LL
WAIT IN THE QUEUE THE MODERATOR
CALL YOUR LINE NUMBER AT THAT
TIME YOU WILL BE ON MUTED AND
YOU'LL BE READY TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE PLEASE NOTE THAT OUR
FOR LOOP PLEASE NOTE THAT IN
ORDER FOR US TO HEAR YOU
CLEARLY AND TO AVOID. BECAUSE
THE FOOD FEEDBACK YOU MUST MUTE
THE DEVICE YOU'RE WATCHING OR
LISTENING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE IT'S
IMPORTANT WE HEAR FROM YOU AND
WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE
I WILL MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING
THE HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY IN
ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO IS
DISRUPTIVE MAY BE REMOVED FROM
THE REMOTE MEETING SERVICE. OR
HAVE THEIR CONNECTIONS OF MUTED
WHILE EVERY EFFORT HAS BEEN
MADE TO STREAMLINE THE HEARING
PROCESS IN OUR CONDUCT AND
CONDUCT OUR HEARINGS AND IS
CLOSE TO THE SAME MANNER AS IS
CUSTOMARY THERE MAY BE SOME LAG
TIME SUBSISTENCE FOR ADJUSTING
TO THE NEW USE OF ONLINE TOOLS
AND TECHNOLOGIES PLEASE BE
RESPECTFUL AND PATIENT TO ALL
THOSE INTERESTED PARTIES. SO
THEY ALL CAN BE HEARD. DUE TO
CONSTRAINTS REGARDING LIKE OF
HEARING. TECHNOLOGY CAN.
INCLUDING PER. I'M A STUDENT.
ARE TESLA EACH SO WILL PERMIT
ECO AMOUNT OF TIME. WHICH IS TO
WITNESSES FOR TWO MINUTES SEE.
ALL WISHING TO TESTIFY MUST
LIMIT THEIR COMMON TO THEIR NEW.
THERE A POSITION ON THE MEASURE.
WHAT MAKES. THAT I WILL PERMIT
HE SIDE SUPPORT BY TO TWO
PRIMARY WITNESSES. AGAIN EACH
PROBABLY WOULD WHAT MINUTES
OPPERMAN E. SIDE A MAX OF FIFTY
MINUTES FROM. WHO MUST LIMIT
THEIR COMMENTS ONCE MORE TO NAY.
FILIATION AND- BEFORE YOUR
PRESENT BILLS THE STILL QUORUM
CHIEF COUNSEL CALL THE- FOR. OF
ITS- A CORE. I'M. AMBERG HERE
FOR J. TO BE DISADVANTAGED
REGIONS THINKING I'M SORRY AT
CAMBIADO. WHITE HOUSE SKI MY
CASKEY HERE WIENER. GORGEOUS
FORGES HERE YOU HAVE A QUORUM
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU AND ONE A
CERTAIN THE STERNS OF. I SEE
HIS OFFICE DISPLAYED WHEN HE
RETURNS WE WILL OF PROPERLY
NOTE HIS RIVAL. ALL RIGHT WE
HAVE A QUORUM WE HAVE SEVEN
BILLS ON TODAY'S AGENDA THROUGH
WHICH I CAN SEND THEM LIKE
CALENDAR ARE AS FOLLOWS SB
THREE FORTY IT'S NUMBER FIVE SB
THREE FORTY BY SENATOR STERN.
FILE NUMBER SIX S. B. FOUR
THREE TWO BY CENTER WHITE CAL
SKI THE FILE NUMBER SEVEN SB
TWO ELEVEN BY SENATOR UMBERG
WITH AMENDMENTS IS EMOTIONAL
CONSENT CALENDAR CENTER
HERTZBERG MOVES THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. ALL RIGHT- VENTURE
THREE CALL THE ROLL ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR- BURKE HI-
BURKE HI BORJAS. FORAGES I
DON'T. COULD BE AT ALL I DID
ALSO. IT ALSO I GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ I HERTZBERG HERTZBERG
AYE JONES JONES I LAYERED.
LAYERED I STERN. STERN AYE
STERN HIGHWAY CAL SKI WHY
CASKEY I WIENER. YOU HAVE A TEN
TWO ZERO SO FAR WITH ONE MEMBER
MISSING THANK YOU MENTERI
COUNCIL AND I KNOW SINISTER'S
YOU KNOW THE PROTOCOL FOR
PARTICIPATING IN REMOTE
HEARINGS- BUT ALSO DO YOU HAVE
A STAFF MEMBER WHO IS PRESENT
WITH YOU. I DO INDEED MISTER
CHAIR I JEREMY WITH MY DISTRICT
DIRECTOR THIS IS LESLIE SARASIN
WHERE'S YOUR BEARD. I LEFT IT
TIGHTENING HEARING WEEK. ALL
RIGHT THAT WILL THAT WILL
PROBABLY WAS LONG ENOUGH TO
HAVE IT FALL OFF ALL RIGHT.
WELL LET'S NOW TURN TO SENATOR
DODD SENATORDODD S. B. THREE
THREE TWO. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS SB THREE
THREE TWO AS INTRODUCED WOULD
HAVE ESTABLISHED A GROSS
DOMESTIC IN A QUESTION CENTER
DOT DO ACCEPT THE AMENDMENTS AS
POLLS ON PAGE ELEVEN TWELVE
COMMENT FIVE DENOUNCES- YOU
KNOW THAT WAS MY NEXT LINE
MISTER CHAIR ALL WELL. I'M
SORRY TO CUT YOU OFF THAT AFTER
DISCUSSIONS WITH YOU MR
CHAIRMAN. IN MY TAM I AM
AGREEING TO AMENDMENTS
DISCUSSED ON PAGES ELEVEN AND
TWELVE OF THE ANALYSIS WOULD
REMOVE THE PROVISIONS IN THE
BILL PERTAINING TO GROSS
NEGLIGENCE PROTECTION. FOR
DAMAGE CLAIMS. THANK YOU CENTER
WHICH THAT WE WOULD APPLY THE
GROSS NEGLIGENCE PROTECTION FOR
BURN BOSSES TO FIRE SUPPRESSION
COSTS. RESULTING FROM THE
OCCURRENCE OF A PRESCRIBED FIRE
ONLY. ENCOURAGING MORE USE OF
PRESCRIBED FIRE THAN CURRENTLY
OCCURS IN THE STATE REMAINS THE
GOAL SB THREE THREE TWO.
ASCRIBE FIRES TYPICALLY DONE OR
SUPERVISOR SUPERVISED BY A BURN
BOSS WHO IS WHO IS QUALIFIED TO
PLAN ORGANIZE AND EXECUTE WHAT
ARE KNOWN AS PRESCRIBED OR
CONTROLLED BURNS PRESCRIBED
FIRES THE CONTROLLED
APPLICATION OF FIRE. TO THE
LAND TO REDUCE WILDFIRE HAZARDS
CLEAR DOWNED TREES CONTROL
PLANT DISEASES IMPROVE
RANGELAND AND WILDLIFE HABITATS
PROVIDE CULTURAL VALUES IN
RESTORED NATURAL ECO SYSTEMS.
MY PRESCRIBER ANNIE IS ONE OF
THE MOST IMPORTANT AND COST
EFFECTIVE TOOLS USED TO REDUCE
WILDFIRE RISK GOVERNOR NEWSOM
HAS INCLUDED PRESCRIBED FIRES A
CENTRAL PIECE OF HIS TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. AND TWENTY TWO ONE
BILLION DOLLAR WILDFIRE
PREVENTION AND RESPONSE BUDGET.
WITH CALIFORNIA HAVING SUFFERED
MORE THAN ONE HUNDRED AND FORTY
EIGHT BILLION DOLLARS OF
WILDFIRE LOSSES OVER THE LAST
DECADE IT'S PARAMOUNT THAT WE
EMPLOY EVERY EFFECTIVE TOOL TO
REDUCE THE FREQUENCY. INTENSITY
AND SCALE OF FUTURE WILDFIRES.
EXPERTS TELL US THE CALIFORNIA
SHOULD BE TREATING A MINIMUM OF
FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND ACRES OF
WILDLAND WITH PRESCRIBED FIRE
EACH YEAR. THE FACT IS.
CALIFORNIA STRUGGLES TO TREAT A
FRACTION OF THAT AMOUNT
ANNUALLY WHILE OTHER STATES
SUCH AS FLORIDA TREAT AS MANY
AS TWO MILLION ACRES A YEAR.
ONE MIGHT ASK WHY IS CALIFORNIA
LAG. THERE ARE SEVERAL REASONS
BUT HUGE FACTORS THAT BURN
BOSSES OF PROPERTY OWNERS FACE
SIGNIFICANT PERSONAL COSTS AND
LIABILITY WE'RE CONDUCTING THIS
WORK EVEN THOUGH IT BENEFITS
SOCIETY AS A WHOLE. ONE OF THE
PRIMARY CONCERNS FOR
PRACTITIONERS IS THAT THEY WILL
BE BILLED OF CAL FIRE PROVIDE
SUPPRESSION SUPPORT ON ONE OF
THOSE BURNS. THE CONCERN OVER
HIGH FIRE SUPPRESSION COST
ENCOURAGED AS A PRACTITIONER IN
LANDOWNER TO AVOID USING
PRESCRIBED FIRE. AND THAT IS
COUNTERPRODUCTIVE TO GETTING
MORE LAND TREATED. THOUGH RARE
IT SOMETIMES CONDITIONS CHANGE
IN SUPPORT IS NEEDED BUT
LANDOWNERS A BIRD BOSSES MAY
CHOOSE NOT TO CALL FOR BACK UP
UNTIL THE FIRE IS GOTTEN OUT OF
CONTROL. AND FRANKLY THAT COULD
BE TOO LATE. AS SB THREE THREE
TWO AS AMENDED WOULD SPECIFY
THE TRAINED AND CERTIFIED BIRD
BOXES. PERSONS THEY SUPERVISE
PROPERTY OWNERS WHO HIRE BURN
BOSSES IN NATIVE AMERICAN
CULTURAL BURNERS ARE SHIELDED
FROM FIRE SUPPRESSION COSTS.
UNLESS THEY CONDUCT A BURN IN A
HIGHLY OR IN A GROSSLY
NEGLIGENT MANNER. EARNED BOSS
WOULD STILL BE LIABLE FOR
SUPPRESSION COSTS IF THEY ACTED
IN A RECKLESS MANNER BUT IF THE
BURKE BUT IF THE BURN BOSSES
CONDUCTING WORK FOR PUBLIC
BENEFIT USING BEST MANAGEMENT
PRACTICES THEY WILL NOT BE
LIABLE FOR THESE RARE BUT-
COSTLY SUPPRESSION EXPENSES. I
BELIEVE THE AMENDED BILL AS A
FAIR COMPROMISE AND I WANT TO
THANK YOU MR- CHAIR IN YOUR
CONSULTANT FOR YOUR HELP IN
REACHING THIS AGREEMENT AND I
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE I VOTE ON
THE PHONE TODAY IN SUPPORT OR
MY- WITNESSES. LANIER QUINN
DAVIDSON AREA FIRE ADVISOR IN
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA
COOPERATIVE EXTENSION. IN
MICHAEL LARA DIRECTOR OF
CLIMATE AND ENERGY POLICY
PROGRAM. THE WOODS INSTITUTE
FOR THE ENVIRONMENT AT STANFORD
UNIVERSITY. THANK YOU SENATOR
DODD- LEN YET ARE YOU AVAILABLE.
FOR MISTER WARREN. YES I'M HERE
THAT MR WAR. YES CAN YOU HEAR
ME YES YES PLEASE PROCEED.
MISTER MARK PLEASE PROCEED
HELLO. SORRY I THOUGHT LIKE IT
WAS GOING FIRST AND YET LEN YET
YOU CANNOT HEAR ME MICHAEL ALL
RIGHT LET'S DO THIS WAY OKAY.
WELL I MISS QUINN DAVIS GO
AHEAD PLEASE. OKAY YOU CAN HEAR
ME YES WE CAN. OKAY SORRY ABOUT
THAT I'M GOOD AFTERNOON AND
THANKS SO MUCH FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY TODAY-
MY NAME IS PLAYING IT COULD
DAVIS AND I AM WITH THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
COOPERATIVE EXTENSION AND THE
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA PRESCRIBED
FIRE COUNCIL I'VE WORKED ON
PRESCRIBED PAYER ISSUES FOR
MORE THAN A DECADE AND I'VE
HELPED INSPIRE AND LEAD THE
GROUNDSWELL OF INTEREST THE
PENCIL THAT IN CALIFORNIA. IN
RECENT YEARS AND THE TIME IS
REALLY RIGHT FOR THE RIGHT
KINDS OF CHANGE ON THIS ISSUE
THE FIRE PRACTITIONERS I CAN
TELL YOU THAT LIABILITY IS ONE
OF OUR BIGGEST BARRIERS COULD
PRESCRIBE FIRE HAS INNUMERABLE
PUBLIC BENEFIT CONFIRMS THE
RELIABILITY KEEP IT FROM
GETTING WORSE. AND WE'RE- LEAD
CURRENT FEDERAL AGENCIES AND
HEALTHCARE ARE SUPPORTED AND
INDEMNIFIED IN THE RARE CASE
SOMETHING GOES WRONG FIRE
EXPERT FROM THE PRIVATE
CULTURAL AN NGO STRUCTURES FACE
IMMENSE PERSONAL LIABILITY. FOR
OUR WORK WHAT. ONLY THE MOST
HIGH AND AMONG US FOR LEADING
IS A- BECAUSE WE WERE EVERY UP
SOME GOES WRONG. THIS IS NOT
THE WAY FOR. TO A NEW MORE OF
SOCIAL WORK. AS WE WERE OUT THE
NEW STATE BUT- PROGRAM A
ALLOCATE MORE. FARM FOR SUCH
FIRE. WE NEED ADDRESS THIS LIEU
WELL OF LIGHT CONCERNS. AND
IT'S A- FORM THE BILL ADDRESS
CIVIL LIABILITY FOR DAMAGES.
AND IT'S REVISED FORM IT TACKLE
COST RECOVERY FOR FIRE
SUPPRESSION. THESE ARE THE TWO
MOST CRITICAL FACETS OF
LIABILITY AND I WISH WE COULD
ADDRESS BOTH I CAN ASSURE YOU
THAT THE BILL IN ITS REVISED
FORM WILL BE HUGELY IMPACTFUL.
BUT STILL HAD SEVENTY FIVE
SUPPORT LETTERS FROM AN
IMPRESSIVELY BROAD BASE
REINSURERS TRIBES
ENVIRONMENTALISTS TIMBER
COMPANIES UNIVERSITIES AND
CONSERVATION ORGANIZATION. HOW
OFTEN DO THOSE GROUPS RALLY IN
SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY CO. THERE
IS ABSOLUTELY NO QUESTION TO
THE PEOPLE WHO USE PRESCRIBED
FIRE THIS BILL IS AN IMPORTANT
PART OF THE SOLUTION. I THINK
SENATOR DODD FOR HIS LEADERSHIP
ON THAT AND FOR THE COMMITTEE-
AND THE COMMITTEE FOR THEIR
TIME TODAY THANK YOU SO MUCH
THANK. YOU PROFESSOR ALL RIGHT
MR TOMORROW. IF YOU'RE. MY
COMMENT THEY REFLECT MY OWN
VIEWS AND NOT THOSE OF MY
EMPLOYER A WILDFIRE FUND FOR
YOUR QUICK FORTY. PROSCRIBES
FIRE PROVIDES LARGE GROWING
BENEFIT THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
IS THE LIABILITY REGIME WE HAVE
TREATED PRIMARILY AS AN
ACTIVITY WITH SOLELY PRIVATE
BENEFITS. THIS BILL TAKES A
MODEST STEP TOWARDS CHANGING
THAT BY ALLOWING FOR BIRDS THAT
ARE PLANNED BY CERTIFIED BIRD
BOXES. HIGHLY SKILLED
PRACTITIONERS AND IT RECEIVES
ALL REQUIRED PERMITS THE
BENEFIT FROM CAL FIRE
SUPPRESSION. UNLESS THEY'RE
CONDUCTED IN A RECKLESS MANNER.
IT IMPORT EMPHASIZED THE BILL
CONTAINS A NUMBER OF GUARD
RAILS TO PREVENT TO BROAD. OF
THIS LIABILITY RELIEF. I WON'T
BE ABLE GET SET UP BY TO OF
BRUSH MY BACK CLEAN RELIEF I
FLETCHER. ONLY BURNS PLAN BY.
AND CONDUCT BY. PERSONNEL
SEPTIC ALL THE PRINTABLE
PERMITS REQUIRED CHALCOPYRITE
IN THE LOCAL AIR DISTRICTS
WOULD BE COVERED UNDER THIS
RELAXATION BUT THE SIMPLE
NEGLIGENCE LIABILITY THAT
OTHERWISE APPLY. HISTORY
APPROACH BALANCE BETWEEN THIS
IS I GOOD BEING PROVIDED BY
PRESCRIBED FIRE PRACTITIONERS
OFTEN FOR LITTLE PAY ON
VOLUNTEER BASIS. AND A MODEST
RISK TO THE PUBLIC BUDGET GOES
BY CAL FIRE RESPONDED TO YOU
AND LETTING IT SIT ON A
PRESCRIBED FIRE. THAT RARE ON A
RARE OCCASION THE STATE'S
CONTAINMENT. ASSEMBLY BILL
WOULD SOCIALIZE THE COST THE
FIREFIGHTING RESOURCES CALLED
TO THE SCENE OF A PRESCRIBED
FIRE. MEET THE STRICT CRITERIA
LAID OUT IN LANGUAGE ARE YOU TO
SUPPORT IT AS AN IMPORTANT STEP
TOWARDS CREATING A WORKFORCE
THAT COULD PROVIDE GREATER
SAFETY FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS.
BUT IF THEY LIVE IN WILDFIRE
COUNTRY BETTER DIRECTLY SUBJECT
TO FIRE FOR ARE SUBJECT TO
TERRIBLE SMOKE IMPACTED
WILDFIRES CREATED SEVENTY
MILLION SUFFERED OVER THE PAST
YEAR. THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK
YOU RESTORE. ALL RIGHT LET'S TO
OTHERS. IN THE GALLERY I SEE
MISTER MCKAY. APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE AHEAD SIR. THANK YOU
MR CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS CHRIS
MCKINLEY ON BEHALF OF THE
MENDOCINO REDWOOD COMPANY IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. I SEE NO ONE ELSE
ANYONE ELSE IN THE GALLERY
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
ALL RIGHT LET'S TURN TO ROOM.
ONE TWELVE ANYONE WANT ONE IN
ROOM ONE TWELVE THE KNOWN IN
ROOM ONE TWELVE ALL RIGHT. NOW
GOING TO THE PHONE LINES. OF
FOR THOSE WISHING TO SUPPORT-
TEST I WISH IN SUPPORT OF SB
THREE THREE TWO- PLEASE QUEUE
UP. GIVE US YOUR NAME YOUR
AFFILIATION AND YOUR POSITION.
MODERATOR DO YOU HAVE ANYONE ON
THE LINE WHICH TO SIGN SUPPORT
OF S. B. THREE THREE TWO. YES
SIR LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB
THREE THREE TWO YOU MAY PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THE TIME. WE
CURRENTLY ABOUT TWENTY
PARTICIPANTS IN Q. WE'LL START
WITH ONE FIFTY FIVE FIFTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. REMEMBER DOLLARS
OR THE STRATEGY THREE SIXTY ON
BEHALF OF THE AMERICAN FOREST
FOUNDATION AND TRANSPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. BY NINETY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YES YOUR
MEMBERS THIS IS BRIAN CHAU HE
CALIFORNIA CLIMATE AND
AGRICULTURE NETWORK IN SUPPORT
I THANK THANK YOU. ONE SEVENTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS CHRIS ROSA ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA COURTS
TO BE A FIFTY CENT IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL. THANK YOU. ONE
FIFTY FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MISTER CHAIR MARK FENSTER MAJOR
POLITICAL OPEN SPACE TRUST IN
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
RESOURCE CONSERVATION DISTRICTS
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU WELL I
NINETY FIVE. MY APOLOGIES NINE
ONE NINETY FIVE RELATED OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON SHARED MEMBERS
CAN HELP YOU KNOW REPRESENTING
CALIFORNIA NATIVE PLANT SOCIETY
OF DEFENDERS OF WILDLIFE IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. ONE ELEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YEAH THIS IS
SEAN CAMPBELL BATTALION CHIEF
CIRCUIT A FIRE DISTRICT- JUST
WANTED TO EXPRESS OUR SUPPORT
FOR SENATE BILL THREE THIRTY
TWO AND OUR TO DO AS WELL
REDUCING LIABILITY FOR
PRESCRIBED BURNS THANK YOU WERE
A LITTLE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT ONE THIRTY THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. THIS IS GAIL EASTWOOD
FOR THE SOUTHERN HUMBOLDT PARK
STATE COUNCIL WHICH STRONGLY
SUPPORT- SB THREE THREE TO THE
WORK OF FUEL PRODUCTION IS
DESPERATELY NEEDED HERE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT. ONE
NINETEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
JOHN ANDERSON WITH HUMBOLDT AND
MENDOCINO REDWOOD COMPANY IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. LINE
FORTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MISTER SHARON NUMBERS COVER
OVER WEEKLY CALIFORNIA
CATTLEMEN'S ASSOCIATION IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF SB THREE
THIRTY TWO THANK YOU THANK YOU.
BLIND TWENTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. ANOTHER DALY WITH THE
WATERSHED RESEARCH TRAINING
CENTER AND ACTING FIRM BOUGHT-
IN TOTAL FOR THE BILL. THANK
YOU. THE WAR. LINE EIGHTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU
KAREN MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
FOR ANY FANTASY WHAT'S YOU'RE A
BUSINESS COUNCIL IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. A LINE
SEVENTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
CRAIG THOMAS DIRECTOR OF THE
FIRE RESTORATION GROUP IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU. LINE
SEVENTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
DEREK CARR BOARD MEMBER FOR
SAVE THE REDWOODS LEAGUE IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. LINE
FIFTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
WE'LL HARLING DIRECTOR THE MAN
CLEMENT WATERSHED COUNCIL AND
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU. A
LINE FORTY TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MY NAME IS STEVIE ROUTE
WITH THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA COOPERATIVE
EXTENSION IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THE BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
ONE FORTY FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI THIS IS JAMIE IRVINE WITH
SIERRA FOREST LEGACY IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. THANK YOU.
LINE FORTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THIS IS SASHA BERLIN
DIRECTOR OF THE FIRE FORWARD
PROGRAM IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SB
THREE THIRTY FEEL THANK YOU.
LINE SEVENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GRATTERI TO THE FEATHER
RIVER RESOURCE CONSERVATION
DISTRICT AND THE QUEEN WITH
UNDER HER COOPERATIVE IN
TROPICAL OR TO. GO THANK YOU.
ONE FIFTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. ANDREW SUMMERS OF THE
CULTURAL FIRE MANAGEMENT
COUNSEL IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU. LINE EIGHTY FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
LIKE MONNING GONNA BE HALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF ELECTRICAL
WORKERS IN THE COALITION OF
CALIFORNIA UTILITY WORKERS A
STRONG SUPPORT OF SB THREE
THREE TWO. THANK YOU THANK YOU.
BY NINETY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MISTER MEMBERS MICHAEL BOUCHARD
ON BEHALF UC OFFICE OF THE
PRESIDENT IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. LINE NINETY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MATT BROWN
DETALJNE CHIEF OF- LOCAL
GOVERNMENT FIRE DEPARTMENT OF
BOYS GENE- STRONG SUPPORT FROM
THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT- FIRE-
PRACTITIONER SIDE. THANK YOU.
VERY HELP LINE EIGHTY FOR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN RICHARD BRYAN WHITE
WITH KP PUBLIC AFFAIRS
REPRESENTING FORCE LANDOWNERS
OF CALIFORNIA SMALL PRIVATE
FOREST LANDOWNERS AND ALSO THE
CALIFORNIA LICENSE FORCED
ASSOCIATION WHICH IS A
REGISTERED PROFESSIONAL
FORESTERS ALSO IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. BY NINETY SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. STEVE GRADING OPEN
CANOPY LLC A PRIVATE LANDOWNER
BURNING STRONG SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. WHAT. LINE EIGHTY NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. LET ON
BEHALF OF PAUL MASON PACIFIC
FOREST TRUST SUPPORT. YEAH
THANK YOU. EXACTLY ONE ONE OH
TO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON THEIR CHILDREN WITH-
I'M THE COORDINATOR OF THE
CENTRAL COAST PRESCRIBED BURN
ASSOCIATION AND OWNER OF
NUMBERFIRE CONSULTING AND I AM
TO THE OPTICALLY APART THANK.
THANK YOU. LINE EIGHTY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. STACKHOUSE ON
BEHALF OF HUMBOLDT COUNTY
PRESCRIBED BURN ASSOCIATION
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. ONE ONE OH
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. JOHN
MOORLACH- FROM FOR THE RIVER
COLLEGE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THE BILL THANK YOU. BEFORE WE
OPEN MY ONE HUNDRED LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN AS A REMINDER IF YOU
WISH TO BECOME A PART OF SB
THREE THREE TWO YOU MAY PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THE TIME BY ONE
HUNDRED WIDE OPEN. YES THANK
YOU TONY TOSO PRESIDENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA CATTLEMEN'S
ASSOCIATION. STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. WE DO HAVE ONE MORE
IN Q. THEY'RE CURRENTLY WITH AN
OPERATOR ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE
OPEN ONE OF FOR ONE ONE FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MY NAME IS
DEVIN FREE FELL AYE AND-
NATURISTS ARE SPECIALISTS OF
PEPPERED PRESERVE AND A
HOMEOWNER WHO LOST THEIR HOMES
IN THE TUBBS FIRE AND I AM IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU. ONE
TWENTY NINE- LINE IS OPEN.
INVESTIGATORS TO CONTROL
COMMITTED. OPERATIVE IN THE
CAPTAIN OF OUR LOCAL LAW
QUICKLY IN YOUR PART OF
ARMENIANS OF THE BILL. THANK
YOU WE HAVE NO ONE OFFERED
SUPPORT. FOR LET'S TURN NOW TO
OPPOSITION UNDERSTAND THEIR TWO
PRIMARY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
EACH WITH TWO MINUTES- SEREN
TAYLOR AND JOHN FISKE. SEVEN
ARE YOU AVAILABLE. I AM BUT I
BELIEVE- JOHN SETS WILL BE
GOING FIRST ALL RIGHT MR FISKE
ARE YOU AVAILABLE IT'S SO GO
AHEAD. I AM THANK YOU A GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS JOHN FISK. ON
THE APPLE CONSUMER ATTORNEYS.
ALL OF CALIFORNIA- WHILE OUR
ORGANIZATION LOOKING STRONG
OPPOSITION TO THE ORIGINAL
LANGUAGE. OF THE BILL- WE DO
APPRECIATE SENATOR DODD AND HIS
STAFF. SENATOR UMBERG AND HIS
STAFF AND THE SENATE JUDICIARY
STAFF. THE REMAINING FLEXIBLE
IN WORKING WITH US ON THE
AMENDED LANGUAGE AT THE BILL.
WE LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING
TO WORK WITH THE SENATORS AS
THE BILL MOVES TO THE PROCESS
WE MAY HAVE SOME ADDITIONAL
LANGUAGE SUGGESTIONS. AT THE
DISCOURSE CONTINUES- BUT WE DO
APPRECIATE THAT SENATOR DR
PERTINENT STAFF SENATOR- BURKE
THAT GROUPS AND THEIR STAFF AS
WELL THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK-YOU. TAYLOR OKAY THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
I'M SHARON TAYLOR YOU'RE ON
BEHALF OF THE PERSONAL
INSURANCE FEDERATION OF
CALIFORNIA. LIKE MR FEST WE
WERE OPPOSED SB THREE THIRTY
TWO. BUT IN LIGHT OF TODAY'S
AMENDMENTS WE WOULD REMOVE OUR
OPPOSITION AND MOVED TO I
SUPPORT AND CONCEPT POSITION.
ENDING THE FINAL LANGUAGE IN
CONSIDERATION OF THAT
CLARIFYING CHANGES SUGGESTED BY
MY COLLEAGUE MISTER SAYS. I'D
ADD THAT YOU KNOW WE HAVE
ALWAYS AGREED WITH THE
UNDERLYING GOAL OF THIS BILL
WHICH IS TO INCREASE USE A
PRESCRIBED BURNS. REDUCE THE
RISK OF CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRES
AND WE THINK SENATOR DODD IN
THE COMMITTEE. FOR WORKING WITH
US TO ACHIEVE A POLICY THAT I
THINK WE CAN ALL SUPPORT CENTER
THANK YOU. DAVIS TAYLOR ALL
RIGHT OTHERS IN OPPOSITION I
SEE NO ONE IN THE GALLERY I SEE
NO ONE IN ROOM ONE TWELVE. OF
THOSE IN OPPOSITION. FEET UP ON
THE PHONE LINE- MODERATOR. DO
YOU HAVE ANYONE A PHONE LINE IN
OPPOSITION TO SB THREE THREE
TWO. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
TO SB THREE THREE TWO YOU MAY
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ACTIVE TIME.
AND WE CURRENTLY HAVE TWO IN Q.
ONE THIRTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN ALL RIGHT PLEASE GIVE US
YOUR NAME YOU'RE STILL. IN
POSITION. THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON CAPITAL CRIMINALS
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION.
OF COUNTIES. WE SUBMITTED A
LETTER OF CONCERN TO THE
COMMITTEE RELATED BUT GROSS
NEGLIGENCE IN OUR EVALUATING
OUR POSITION BASED ON ADOPTED
AMENDMENTS THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
NINE ONE OH NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. I'M CALLING IN SUPPORT
MOST OF THE MISSED THE ONE SO
I'M ABOUT PARIKH MENDOCINO
COUNTY- MONITOR OF COURSE PLAN
ARE PULLING IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. MODERATOR ANYONE
ELSE ON THE PHONE MAYBE. I'M
SORRY GO AHEAD. YES OBJECTS FOR
YOU MY APOLOGIES LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF SB THREE THREE
TWO YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. AND RIGHT NOW WE
CURRENTLY HAVE ONE YOU
CURRENTLY WITH AN OPERATOR ONE
MOMENT PLEASE.
THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PATIENCE ALL BUT MY NUMBER
EIGHTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO THIS IS JENNY BEGINNING
WITH THE NATURE CONSERVANCY
CALLING IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
BOTHER ANYBODY ELSE ON THE
PHONE LINE. NO ONE OF THE PHONE
LINE ALL RIGHT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WILL BRING YOU BACK TO THE
CHAMBERS HE SAID WHAT COUNTS
CONSIDER LITTERED WITH THEIR
MICROPHONES UP CENTER BY CAL
SKI. YEAH FOR I HAVE A QUESTION
FOR DOCTOR WAR I'M REVIEWING
THE STANFORD WOULD SET A- NEW
STRATEGY FOR ADDRESSING THE
WILDFIRE EPIDEMIC. IN
CALIFORNIA AND- IT INDICATES
THAT WE SHOULD BE SPENDING A
BILLION DOLLARS. TO TREAT A
MILLION ACRES A YEAR. IN ORDER
TO RECEIVE THE BENEFITS. OF-
REDUCE REDUCE FUEL- THIS WELL
THIS. THIS BILL WILL TAKE CARE
OF THE LIABILITY PROBLEM YOUTH
DO YOU THINK THAT THAT'S GOING
TO ACCELERATE THE- I GUESS THE
LIKELIHOOD THAT PEOPLE GET A
BURNER TO BE MORE FUNDS COMING
HI I'M AND I'M WONDERING IF
WE'RE ONLY SPENDING FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR IF
THAT'S GOOD IF IT IS COULD MAKE
AN APPRECIABLE IMPACT ON THE
NEW LANDSCAPE TREATMENT THAT-
WHAT THE RISK PROTECTION THAT
YOU'RE- HOPING TO EFFECTUATE BY
THE BILL. WHO ARE YOU WELL WHAT
I'D SAY. OUR SYSTEM CENTER IS
THAT WE HAVE A LONG WAY TO GO
ON HOW WE MANAGE FORESTLANDS IN
CALIFORNIA AND WE HAVE A
CENTURY OF- YOU CALL IT THE
BIRD MAINTENANCE YOU COULD CALL
IT BAD DECISION MAKING OR
DECISION MAKING REQUIRE REGRET
NOW BUT- THIS BILL IS A SMALL
PIECE OF A VERY COMPLEX PUZZLE.
AND PART OF THAT PUZZLE IS
GONNA INVOLVED WORKING WITH
PRIVATE LANDOWNERS WITH THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND WITH
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO GET
TO THAT MILLION FOR TARGET BUT
I DO THINK THAT IN THE LONG RUN
THAT KIND OF THE SCALE IS WHAT
WE SHOULD AIM FOR IN ORDER TO
FULLY TREAT AND REALLY
DRAMATICALLY ALTER A SITUATION
THAT IS BEING SUPER CHARGED BY
CLIMATE CHANGE. SORRY THANK YOU.
FIVE I SEE CENTER STERN'S HANDS
UP ALSO BUT LET'S TURN TO
SENATOR LAYER THAN CENTER STERN
CENTER LAWYER THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MR CHAIRMAN I WAS GOING TO
SPEAK TO THE BILL BUT I THINK I
WILL ALSO INCORPORATE OF THE
CONCERN OF SENATOR WHITE HOUSE
SKIER IN MY COMMENTS BECAUSE-
THE- THE THIRD CALLER WAS
EXACTLY RIGHT. THE THERE'S- A
HUNDRED YEARS OF FIRE
SUPPRESSION THAT IS BROUGHT UP
AGAINST CLIMATE CHANGE AND IS
LED TO. WHAT NEEDS TO BE A
MAJOR CHANGE IN WHAT WE DO TO
PREVENT FIRE. THE STATE HAS
BEEN DOING IT YEAR BY YEAR AND
THE CURRENT GOAL. WAS TO DO
FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND ACRES OF
PRESCRIBED FIRE IT UP- IN A
YEAR. AND I THINK WHAT SENATOR
DODD SAID AT SOME POINT IN THIS
PROCESS. IS THE ONLY A HUNDRED
AND TWENTY THOUSAND ACRES OF
THE FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND.
ACRES WAS ABLE TO BE DONE
BECAUSE OF THE ISSUES THAT ARE
AT PLAY- IN THIS. AND I THINK
SENATOR WHITE HOUSE SKI RAISES
THE ISSUE THAT'S CORRECT. OUR
WHICH IS THAT IT MAY WELL NOT
BE ENOUGH AND IT MAY WELL HAVE
TO OVERTIME BE HIGHER. AND THE
REAL THING IS THAT WE'VE BEEN
DOING EVEN THOUGH RESOURCES NOW
HAS A FIVE YEAR PLAN WE'VE BEEN
DOING IT YEAR TO YEAR AND I'VE
A BILL TO PUT TOGETHER A FIVE
YEAR PLAN. BUT THAT'S AND
THAT'S WHY A LOT OF THE
WITNESSES CALLED IN NY SENATOR
WHITE HOUSE YET SAYS QUESTION
WHICH WAS ON THE POLICY. OF OF
FIRE PREVENTION BUT WHAT'S IN
FRONT OF US IN THE JURISDICTION
OF THE COMMITTEE. IS THE
LIABILITY PIECE THAT I THINK
THAT ORIGINALLY THERE WAS.
CONCERN ABOUT THE LIABILITY
SECTION AND I'M SURE ALL OF US
WOULD BE CONCERNED. IF WE
DIDN'T HAVE IT AND FIRES WERE
BURNING RIGHT AT OUR
CONSTITUENTS WITH NOBODY HAVING
ANY LIABILITY. AND I THINK
THROUGH THE WORK OF THE CHAIR
AND HIS STAFF AND SENATOR DODD
AND HIS STAFF WE HAVE A
WORKABLE ALTERNATIVE THAT
ALLOWS US TO MEET BOTH GOALS.
DUE TO THE FIRE PREVENTION PART
THAT EVERYBODY CALLED IN ABOUT
TO SEE A SENATOR WHITE HOUSE HE
WAS CONCERNED IF THE REAL
SUPPRESSOR IN THE NUMBER OF
ACRES THAT WAS BEING DONE WAS
THE LIABILITY ISSUE. AND IF
IT'S NOT THE NOT SOMETHING ON
THE POLICY LEVEL WE WILL HAVE
TO ADDRESS SEPARATELY AND I'M
SURE OVER TIME. THERE WILL BE
QUESTIONS ABOUT WHETHER WHAT
WAS SUPPOSED IS TOTALLY
WORKABLE BUT I THINK IT'S A
GOOD SOLUTION AND AT THE RIGHT
TIME I'M GONNA BE READY TO MOVE
THE BILL AND I REALLY
APPRECIATE THE WORK OF THE
AUTHOR AND THE CHAIR. IN
GETTING US TO THIS POINT. THANK
YOU. CENTER LAYERED US STERN
WITH YOUR HAND RAISED. INDEED
IT WAS MISTER CHAIR ALL RIGHT
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU-
CONSIDERABLE- KNOW HOW ON OUR
COMMITTEE HERE AT- EVIDENCED BY
MY COLLEAGUES COMMENTS- NOT THE
LEAST OF WHICH AT THE AUTHOR
INCREDIBLE LEADERSHIP TIME
AFTER TIME IN THIS ARENA- AND
YOU'RE WORKING THROUGH THE
PROBLEMS THIS BILL IS THAT
PRESCRIBED FIRE IS NOT AN EASY
ISSUE ALWAYS- BUT I THINK THE
FRAMEWORK YOU PUT FOR TODAY. AS
GOING TO MOVE THE BALL FORWARD
I DO WANT TO MAKE A POINT OF
CLARIFICATION IF I COULD WITH
THE AUTHOR MISTER CHAIR. SIR
THE BILL DOESN'T MANDATE OR-
IMPOSE PRESCRIBED FIRES IN ALL
THE COLLEGES AROUND THE STATE
CORRECT IT'S REALLY ABOUT THE
LIABILITY RELATED TO THE BURN
BOSSES WHO ARE CERTIFIED.
THROUGH THE PROCESS IS THAT
RIGHT. EVERY EVERY JURISDICTION
HAS THE OPPORTUNITY TO DO
WHATEVER THEY WANT TO TRY TO
MANAGE FIRES IN THIS AREA THIS
JUST HANDLES THE LIABILITY OF
PUTTING OUT THOSE FIRES SHOULD
ONE GET AWAY. SO I THINK
EVERYONE ACROSS THE STATE
SHOULD BE ENTHUSIASTIC THAN
ABOUT THIS BILL BECAUSE WHAT
YOU'RE BASICALLY SAYING IS WE
TRUST IN OUR GOVERNMENT OR
LOCAL GOVERNMENT OR IN CAL
FIRE. TO BE THE DECIDERS ON
WHERE THESE THINK WHERE THIS IS
APPROPRIATE AND ALSO. TO BE THE
BACKSTOPS BECAUSE ESSENTIALLY
WHAT YOU KNOW WHAT SARAH CASKEY
WAS TALKING ABOUT IS THAT THE
WAY NOW THIS IS NEGLIGENCE
STANDARD HAS BEEN SHIFTED. THE
BACKSTOP OF THAT LIABILITY ENDS
UP BEING ON. ON EITHER LOCAL OR
STATE GOVERNMENT OR FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT BUT THERE'S A SORT
OF PUBLIC BACKSTOPS NOW AND I'M
WILLING TO. INVEST THAT TRUST I
GUESS WITH HIS VOTE IN OUR
AGENCIES IN OUR FRAMEWORK AND
THAT MAY REQUIRE AUGMENTATIONS
OF FUNDING TO BOLSTER THAT
BACKSTOP BUT I THINK THAT'S A
WORTHY PUBLIC INVESTMENT. AND I
GUESS THAT THAT WOULD BE. I
JURISDICTIONAL YES WITH A
NEGLIGENCE STANDARD BUT THAT
STANDARD ITSELF WILL DICTATE-
THE BROADER FUNDING LANDSCAPE
GOING FORWARD I THINK THAT'S A
GOOD THING. I THINK YOU'RE
YOU'RE YOU'RE BREAKING THROUGH
HERE SO INDUSIA ASK LEE HI
THANKS FOR YOUR WORK. THANK YOU.
OTHER MICROPHONES OTHER
COMMENTS ALL RIGHT LET'S BRING
IT BACK. OF WILL BRING BACK THE
CHAIR THANK YOU SENATOR DODD
YOUR PASSION YOUR- INTEREST
YOUR FLEXIBILITY- ALSO SEE
MYSELF WITH ALL THE OTHER KUDOS
THAT HAVE BEEN- PROVIDER HOPE
YOU RECALL MY COMMENTS SHOULD
IN MY BILLS APPEAR IN YOUR
COMMITTEE. STILL ARE HAVING
SAID THAT CENTER LIVES MOVED A
MAN CHIEF COUNSEL- WELL LET'S
SENATOR DODD CLOSE AND THEN
WILL CALL THE ROLL. I'D LIKE TO
THANK- THE MEMBERS WHO MADE
COMMENTS IN THE MEMBERS THAT I
CONTACTED- YOU OVER THE WEEKEND
AS WE- WERE ABLE TO GET THESE
AMENDMENTS DONE. AS MY GOOD
COLLEAGUE- CENTER WHITE HOUSE
HE POINTED OUT. THAT WE HAD TWO
FANTASTIC- EXPERTS THAT WERE-
MY SPEAKERS HERE ONE FROM
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA AND ONE
FROM STANFORD UNIVERSITY. YEAH
THAT'S PRETTY GOOD WHEN THEY'LL
COME TOGETHER AND- IF YOU'LL
REALLY FIGHT HARD. FOR A GOOD
POLICY IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU. THERE
ARE NONE SEVENTY COUNCIL PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. THIS IS THE S.
B. THREE THREE TWO BY SENATOR
DODD WITH A MOTION BY SENATOR
WHERE THE MOTION IS DO YOU PASS
AS AMENDED NUMBER. UMBERG BY
BORGIAS FIVE FORGES I W. AT ALL
HI. I DID ALSO. GONZALEZ HI
GONZALEZ I HERTZBERG. JONES
JONES I LAYERED HI LAYERED I
STERN. STERN HIGHWAY CAL SKI
WHY CASKEY AYE WIENER ALL RIGHT
WIENER AYE YOU HAVE NINE TWO
ZERO SO FAR. OKAY HERTZBERG.
HERTZBERG HI YOU HAVE TEN TWO
ZERO ONE MEMBER MISSING ALL
RIGHT WE'LL PUT THAT BILL ON
CALL THANK YOU CENTER DIED NEXT
WE HAVE CENTER LABELS BEEN
WAITING. AND AFTER WE CLEAN THE
PODIUM CENTER LEYVA S. B. THREE
SIX THREE. GOOD AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIR GOOD AFTERNOON
MEMBERS. I AM HAPPY TO BE HERE
AND I AM OFFERING AMENDMENTS TO
SP THREE SIXTY THREE I THINK
EVERYONE HAS RECEIVED THOSE
MISTER CHAIR YOU HAVE RECEIVED%
THEM AS WELL. SENATE BILL THREE
SIXTY THREE FURTHERS
CALIFORNIA'S GOAL OF PROVIDING
EQUITABLE EDUCATION
OPPORTUNITIES TO ALL STUDENTS
BY REQUIRING BOTH BOYS STATE
AND GIRLS STATE PROGRAMS TO
OFFER SUBSTANTIALLY SIMILAR
SIMILAR COSTS CURRICULUM.
SUBSTANTIALLY SIMILAR ACCESS TO
GO OFFICES OFFICIALS EMPHASIZE.
EQUAL NUMBER OF. FOR TO PROTEST.
AS THERE ARE FOR BOYS. ANY ON
THE NUMBER OF STUDENTS NAMA PER
SCHOOL SHALL APPLY TO BOTH
PROGRAMS AND NON BINARY
STUDENTS MAY APPLY EITHER
PROGRAM. THIS BILL WILL ENSURE
THAT THE AMERICAN LEGION AND
THE AMERICAN LEGION AUXILIARY
PROVIDE SUBSTANTIALLY SIMILAR
SIMILAR ACCESS AND
OPPORTUNITIES TO STUDENTS AS
WELL AS NOT DISCRIMINATE BASED
ON GENDER. CALIFORNIA BOYS
STATE AND GIRLS STATE PROGRAMS
ARE INTENDED TO IMPACT AND
IMPORT A BETTER UNDERSTANDING
OF GOVERNMENT AND CIVIC
RESPONSIBILITIES AS WELL AS
PARTICIPATE IN ACTIVELY IN THE
PRIVILEGES AND RESPONSIBILITIES
OF DEMOCRACY. CALIFORNIA HAS
LONG HELD THAT ACCESS TO
EDUCATION IS A FUNDAMENTAL
RIGHT OF ALL PERSONS REGARDLESS
OF THEIR GENDER. SADLY YOUNG
WOMEN PARTICIPATING CALIFORNIA
GIRL STATE ARE NOT AFFORDED
COMPATIBLE CIVICS EDUCATION
OPPORTUNITIES AS YOUNG MEN IN
CALIFORNIA BOYS STATE EVERY
YEAR WITH THE EXCEPTION OF THE
YEAR OF A PANDEMIC
APPROXIMATELY ONE THOUSAND
YOUNG MEN PARTICIPATE IN BOISE
STATE VISIT SACRAMENTO AND
STATE CAPITOL DURING THE SUMMER
MANY OF YOU PROBABLY REMEMBER
THESE VISITS. CALIFORNIA GIRLS
STATE WITH THE NINETEEN
EIGHTIES YOU'RE A CAP OF
APPROXIMATELY FIVE HUNDRED AND
FORTY PARTICIPANTS ARE ABLE TO
PARTAKE IN SOME ASPECTS OF
CIVIC EDUCATION. BUT ARE NOT
AFFORDED THE SAME ACCESS AND
OPPORTUNITY TO THEIR GOVERNMENT
AS BOYS MOST NOTABLY IN COMING
TO SACRAMENTO AND VISITING
THEIR STATE CAPITAL. ONE CANNOT
TO DOT DENIED THE PROGRAM'S
PRESENCE IN SACRAMENTO AFFORDS
OPPORTUNITIES THAT STUDENTS MAY
NOT OTHERWISE HAVE. OTHER
ECONOMIC WORRIES ALSO EXIST
SUCH AS APPLICATION FEES
REGISTRATION FEES CAREER FAIRS
AND THE LEARNING OF OUTDATED
SONGS THAT FOCUS MORE ON THE
APPEARANCE OF YOUNG GIRLS THAN
ACTUAL CIVICS. IT IS IMPORTANT
THAT YOUNG WOMEN ARE OFFERED
THE SAME OPPORTUNITIES AND SAME
TYPE OF EXPOSURE TO THE
GOVERNMENT AS OUR YOUNG MEN. IN
THE WORDS OF SALLY RIDE THE
FIRST WOMAN IN SPACE YOU CANNOT
BE WHAT YOU CANNOT SEE. SO IT
IS CRITICALLY IMPORTANT THAT
YOUNG WOMEN ARE NOT
DISADVANTAGED AND ARE ALSO ABLE
TO VISIT THE HALLS OF POWER IN
SACRAMENTO AND THE CAPITAL IF
THE YOUNG MEN PARTICIPATING
INVOICE STAKE IT TOO AS WELL.
MEMBERS I LOOK FORWARD TO AN
AYE VOTE AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME IN SUPPORT WITH ME HERE
TODAY. IS JESSICA STENDER WITH
EQUAL RIGHTS ADVOCATES AS WELL
SHELBY ENGLE WHO IS A TWO
THOUSAND EIGHT GIRLS STATE
ALONE. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
THANK YOU CENTER LEYVA- THIS
STANDARD ARE YOU AVAILABLE. BUT
GO AHEAD CLOSURES. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
JESSICA SKINNER AND I'M
INTERNET ADVOCATES AND
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION
DEDICATED TO PROTECTING AND
EXPANDING ECONOMIC AND
EDUCATIONAL THAT GIRL SB THREE
SIX THREE A DROP IN TH GENDER
BASED INEQUITY THAT HAVE
CAPITULATED. BY AN OUTDATED
EXCEPTION TO THE- XIN CÃM IN
OUR STATE EDUCATION. IF IT'S
FOR ACTIVITIES THE AMERICAN
LEGION AND CUSTOMARY
EDUCATIONAL INSTITUTION.
RELATED TO THE BOYS AND GIRLS
DECOMPENSATED WAS INCLUDED IN
YOUR ORIGINAL EXCEPTION IN
TITLE NINE OF THE FEDERAL
LEVEL. THE TIMELINE EXCEPTION
WAS THE RESULT IN A POLITICAL
COMPROMISE AND WHILE IT MAY
ARGUABLY HAVE BEEN INTENDED TO
USE CERTAIN ORGANIZATIONS.
LEGALLY MANDATE MANDATED AFTER
FROM ND GIRLS ANY SUCH
RATIONALITY OUTLIVED PURPORTED
JUSTIFICATION. ACTUALLY IN
LIGHT OF THE GENDER BASE
INEQUITY BETWEEN CONFERENCE.
FINAL OF THE INTENT AND PURPOSE%
OF OUR STATE EDUCATION FOR THE
RIGHT LAW WHICH PROHIBITS
DISCRIMINATION IT IS MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT THE AUTHOR
IS TAKING AMENDMENTS AFTER MUCH
HARD WORK WITH THE STAKEHOLDERS
WE ULTIMATELY SUPPORT ECONOMIC
FUNDING WOULD REQUIRE
SUBSTANTIALLY SIMILAR
PROGRAMMING AS WELL AS
POTENTIALLY EQUAL ACCESS TO
GOVERNMENT OFFICIALS AND
FACILITY. ANY ONE OF OUR
PARTICIPANTS. AND ACCESS TO NON
BINARY. THE GOAL HERE WOULD NOT
HARM PROGRAM HAVE NEARLY TO
BRING A STATE PROGRAM TO PAR
THE BOYS THE PROGRAM. IN AN ERA
MORE WOMEN THAN EVER RUNNING
FOR OFFICE IS INSURED IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA SO THE WAY
AND HELPING THESE PROBLEMS
CREATE A PIPELINE PROGRAMS. I
PLAN TO BRING A- YOU ONE DAY
WERE AFTER OFFICE. ALLOWING
GENDER DISCRIMINATION
ESPECIALLY WHILE USING PUBLIC
RESOURCES AND EVEN OUR STATE
LEGISLATURE FLIES IN THE FACE
OF THE IN OUR STATE. SB THREE
SIX THIRTY PROVIDE A PATH TO
CREATING MUCH NEEDED CHANGE
THESE PROGRAMS. AND ENSURE THAT
OUR EDUCATION EQUITY LAW LIVES
UP TO ITS PURPOSE OF PREVENTING
SEXTAPE WITH TERMINATION AND
EDUCATIONAL PROGRAMS
ACTIVITIES. FOR THESE REASONS
WE RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
IDOL THANK YOU. RAMOS TENDER-
THIS EGG BALL. HELLO MY NAME IS
SHELBY ALL I DID TEN GIRLS. TWO
THOUSAND EIGHT. AND RETURN THE
JUNIOR COUNSELOR IN TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN. WHY BIRTH
ATTENDED GIRLS STATE. I FOUND
THE PROGRAM TO BE EMPOWERING
AND I WAS SO EXCITED TO BE
SELECTED TO REPRESENT HIGH
SCHOOL. IN SUCH A PRESTIGIOUS
PROGRAM. I LOVE TWENTY
COMMUNITY INCLUDING ALL THE
AMBITIOUS YOUNG WOMEN ACROSS
THE STATE BY LEARNING ABOUT
GOVERNMENT. WHEN I CAME BACK
FROM GIRLS STATE. I LEARNED
WHAT MY MALE COUNTERPART IT
POLICE STATE. NOT ONLY WAS IT A
LARGER COULD OPEN UP WITH TWO
BOYS FROM HIGH SCHOOL AND
REGULARLY COMPARED TO THE ONE
THAT HAD THE GIRL STATE. BUT
EVEN IN THE CAPITAL LIMITED
THERE ARE. NOT THAT BACKED
BOPPERS ARE. HE PARTICIPATED
INCLUDING COLLEGES. FOR THEY
WERE EVEN AWARDED RECOGNIZE
HELPS. ONE OF THE SAME
OPPORTUNITY WORKFORCE TO US
IT'S ALL LIKE WE WERE TO FAST
IN THE LAST FIVE CLEANERS LAST
THERE BEING THE TOPIC. SURELY
BECAUSE OF OUR GENDERWITHOUT
EXPOSURE AND OPPORTUNITY THE
BOYS RECEIVED SOMETHING TOWARDS
OPENED THOUSAND LEFT WALKS TO A-
I THOUGHT PARKING TOTAL IN.
SONG STATE OF. GREAT AFTER
TALKING A GIRLS GER WALKS DOWN
THE STREET TRADITIONS OF
PROGRAM OUTDATED NOT OUTDATED
STRAW. WHAT I DISCUSSED THE
BOOK THE LOCATION ISSUE
DIFFERENT GIRLS. BURKE I'VE
BEEN TOLD MANY DIFFERENT
COMPETING AFTER ALL IT'S NOT
THAT THEY DON'T WANT CHANGE AND
CONTINUOUS ANOTHER REJECTION
EVEN WHEN I PUT IN THE EFFORT
ALL THE NEW TURNOUT THE CAPITAL
TO GET CERTIFICATE THE GIRL
CLEANERS THEY NEVER PROVIDED ME
WITH THE INFORMATION NEEDED TO
FIGHT THANK THEY WORK WITH
LOCAL CHECK CONSTRUCTING. THIS
NEEDS TO CHANGE THE MILLIONS OF
YOUNG WOMEN IN THE STATE
DESERVE BETTER AND YOU TO VOTE
YES ON A CELL THANK YOU. RAMOS
SAID DAHLE ALL RIGHT I SEE THE
BILL STATES PAYING OFF IN TERMS
OF YOUR CIVIC INVOLVEMENT-
LET'S NOW TURN TO THE GALLERY
OTHERS IN SUPPORT THE GALLERY
SAYING NONE ROOM ONE TWELVE
AGAIN ROOM ONE TWELVE SEEING
NONE. I'M NOT A MODERATELY
WOULD QUEUE UP THOSE ON THE
PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF. IT S.
B. THREE SIX THREE. LADIES AND
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK OF THE OF
S. THREE SIX THREE YOU MAY BE.
ONE ZERO AT THE TIME. AND ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF SB THREE SIX THREE
YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AND I SHOW NO ONE AT THE
PORT. ALL RIGHT ET'S NOW TURN
TO OPPOSITION I'D TWO WITNESSES
LISTED IS IN PRINCIPLE
OPPOSITION TIM- OF THE RAW- ABU
DARA IN VALERIE HEARTY- MISTER
ABU DAR ARE YOU ONLINE. MS
HARDY ARE YOU ON THE LINE. YES
I'M ON THE LINE ALL RIGHT
MCCARTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON SENATOR- BURKE AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I'M
VALERIE HARDY FORMER DIRECTOR
AND CHIEF COUNSELOR AMERICAN
LEGION AUXILIARY CALIFORNIA
GIRLS STATE AND IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY DELEGATE. FIRST AND
FOREMOST THE EXECUTIVE SUMMARY
ST LA CALIFORNIA GIRL STATE
ENTIRELY EXCLUDE NON BINARY
STUDENTS. IT'S NOT TRUE AS WE
HAVE HAD TO OPENLY NON BINARY
DELEGATES TO EXCEL AT THE GIRLS
STATE REFLECTED TO ATTEND ALAY
GIRLS NATION I CONTINUE TO
RETURN TO CALIFORNIA GIRL STATE
APART OF OUR ALL VOLUNTEER
STAFF. OUR DIVERSE STAFF OF AND
SEEKS TO EMPOWER DELEGATE TO
FIND THEIR VOICES AND BUILD
STRONG UPLIFTING RELATIONSHIPS
WITH THEIR PEERS WHILE LEARNING
ABOUT CIVIC ENGAGEMENT. WE
UNDERSTAND THE INTENT OF SB
THREE SIXTY THREE AND APPLAUD
THE AUTHORS FOR THEIR WORK TO
ENSURE GENDER EQUALITY. AFTER
READING THE LATEST AMENDMENT
MARKUPS FOUND IN THE COMMITTEES
EXECUTIVE SUMMARY WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH SENATOR
LEYVA TO CLARIFY DETECTED
AMENDMENT HAVE MOVING FORWARD
AS A LEADERSHIP TEAM WITH
AMERICAN LEGION CALIFORNIA BOYS
STATE. WE PROPOSED AND
IMPLEMENT DEADLINE OF JUNE
THIRTIETH TWENTY TWENTY THREE
WHICH WOULD ALLOW US TO PLAN
FOR NECESSARY CHANGES THAT
WOULD NOT ONLY ADDRESS THE
AUTHORS CONCERNED. BUT ALSO
STRENGTHENED OUR PROGRAM. WE
NOTED THE PHRASE SUBSTANTIALLY
SIMILAR ACCESS TO GOVERNMENT
OFFICIALS AND FACILITIES.
IDENTIFY THE PROSPECT OF
OFFERING OUR DELEGATES THE
OPPORTUNITY TO WORK WITH AND
LEARN FROM THEIR LOCAL
LEGISLATORS. TO ENSURE THAT
THIS OPPORTUNITY OF MEETING
CALL AT THE CASTLE WE LOOK
FORWARD TO OUR LEGISLATORS
MAKING IT A PERSONAL PRIORITY
TO SHARE THEIR PASSION FOR
PUBLIC SERVICE WITH OUR YOUNG
LEADERS. WE CONSISTENTLY REVIEW
AND REFLECT OUR PROGRAMMING TO
ENSURE THAT WE ARE MEETING THE
NEEDS OF ALL DELEGATE.
RECOGNIZING THE GAP IN ACCESS
AND EXPOSURE TO HIGHER
EDUCATION WE BEGAN OFFERING A
COLLEGE FAIR TO ALL DELEGATES
DURING THE TWENTY TWENTY
SESSION WE HAVE WORKED
DILIGENTLY TO DESIGN AN
ENRICHING PROGRAM THAT OFFERS A
VARIETY OF EXPERIENCES FOR
DELEGATES TO BE ACTIVELY
INVOLVED THROUGHOUT THE WEEK.
TO LEGISLATE IN DETAIL THE
CONTENT OF OUR PROGRAM WOULD
UNDERMINE THE WORK OF OUR
LEADERSHIP TEAM AND THE
INTEGRITY OF BOTH PROGRAM.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME TODAY
THANK YOU MISS HARDY- MISTER
ABU DAR ARE YOU AVAILABLE. YES
CAN YOU HEAR ME NOW- YES WE
CAN'T GO AHEAD SIR. GOOD
AFTERNOON SENATOR BYRD AND
MEMBERS OF THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS PAM EVAN
YOU'RE A SENIOR I'VE BEEN
SERVING AS THE CHIEF COUNSELOR
OF THE AMERICAN LEGION
CALIFORNIA BOYS STATE PROGRAM
SINCE TWO THOUSAND AND EIGHT
I'VE BEEN A MEMBER OF THE STAFF
NOW FOR FORTY SEVEN YEARS. AND
WAS AN ALARM AN ALARM OF THE
PROGRAM FOR MY YEARS IN HIGH
SCHOOL. AT THE OUTSET WE WERE
VERY MUCH IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL. WILL DRAFT IN THE FIRST
THE SECOND DRAFT WITH
AMENDMENTS I'M GOING TO SPEAK
TO WHERE WE ARE WITH THE MOST
RECENT SET OF AMENDMENTS HAS
SHOWN IN THE BILL ANALYSIS. IN
PREPARATION FOR TODAY'S HEARING
WE HAVE SPOKEN WITH SOME OF YOU
AND OR MEMBERS OF YOUR
RESPECTIVE STAFFS. APPEARS TO
BE REAL AGREEMENT AT THE
AMERICAN LEGION CALIFORNIA BOYS
STATE PROGRAM AT LA GIRL STATE
PROGRAM. OUR GREAT ONE STEP
BETTER PROVIDED BY TWO SEPARATE
OUTSTANDING VETERANS SERVICE
ORGANIZATIONS ARE RUN BY
VOLUNTEERS OUR CONCERNS WITH
THE AMENDMENTS TO ENCODE TWO
TWENTY FOUR. IS THE REGULATION
OF THESE TWO PROGRAMS. LET'S
JUST LEGALIZING OR LEGISLATING
CONTROL OVER THEM IN SPITE OF
THE FACT THAT NEITHER
SPONSORING ENTITY HAS CONTROL
OVER THE OTHER. FIFTY
INTERDICTION OF THIS
LEGISLATION BOTH PROGRAMS HAVE
COME TOGETHER AND PROPOSED A
NON LEGISLATIVE SOLUTION THAT
WE BELIEVE MEETS THE AUTHORS
GOALS. WE BELIEVE THAT MANY
PIECES OF THAT SOLUTION ARE
CODIFIED IN THE MOST. RECENT
MOCK UP IN THE BILL ANALYSIS IN
ADDITION THE AMERICAN LEGION
CALIFORNIA BOYS STATE PROGRAM
HAS COMMITTED TO ASSISTING. A
LA CALIFORNIA GIRL STATE BY
CONNECTING THEM WITH ALL OF OUR
SACRAMENTO CONTACTS TO ASSIST
THEM WITH BEING MORE ALIGNED
WITH OUR PROGRAM ENNIS'S TEAM
THEM. WITH THIS MOVES
TRANSITION. WELL BOTH
CONFERENCE HAVE A SIM CORRECT
AS IN. A TO OF OUR OPPOSITION
STATE. SIX MY DOES NOT PROVIDE
EITHER CONFERENCE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO BE IN FULL
ALIGNMENT. JANUARY ONE TWENTY
TWENTY THANK YOU MR OF THE DOOR.
THOSE BY BOTH CONFERENCES THANK
YOU SIR- ALL RIGHT WELL LET'S
NOW TURN TO OTHERS IN
OPPOSITION IN THE GALLERY
OTHERS IN OPPOSITION SEEING
NONE ROOM ONE TWELVE SEEING
NONE LET'S TURN TO THE PHONE
LINES FOR THOSE ON THE PHONE
LINES PLEASE GIVE US YOUR NAME
AND YOUR AFFILIATION. AND YOUR
POSITION. MADAME MODERATOR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
OPPOSITION TO SB. THREE SIX
THREE. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
OF SB THREE SIXTY THREE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. AT THIS
TIME. AND CURRENTLY THE PHONE
LINES WE HAVE THIRTEEN Q.
ALREADY THANK YOU. YOU'RE
WELCOME WILL START ROLLING
FORTY REMINDED OPEN. A NEW
RECORD YOU KNOW- PRESIDENT
BALLARD VETERANS ALLIANCE OF
ORANGE COUNTY AND WE STAND IN
STRONG STRONG AND WAVERING
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. THANK YOU.
ONE SEVENTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. ELLEN CAL YOU KNOW THEY
TALK WHEN YOU GO STAY ON THEM I
TOLD BILL AS WRITTEN. THANK YOU.
LINE THIRTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. BAKER SHOULD JACKSON
KELLY LEGISLATIVE AREA FOR
COUNT ONE STRONG OPPOSITION OF
THIS BILL. THANK YOU. ONE
SEVENTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO MY NAME IS PATRICIA
MARTINEZ FROM THE AMERICAN
LEGION AUXILIARY DISTRICT
EIGHTEEN UNITS EIGHT THIRTY
FROM CALIFORNIA AND I APOLOGIZE
THIS BILL AS AMENDED. THANK YOU
HERE. ONE ONE SEVENTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI THIS IS EVAN
MINTON WITH PLACES FOR PROGRESS
I APOLOGIZE FOR BEING IN THAT
LONG HEREBY PLEASE STAND IN
IMPORTANT OUT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. LINE THIRTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME IS CANCER AND I AM A
TWENTY FOUR MONTH- YOU'RE A
MEMBER OF THE AMERICAN LEGION
AUXILIARY AND VOLUNTEER AND I
STRONGLY AGREE WITH THIS BILL
AS WRITTEN BUT THE STAFF
EQUIPMENT TO THE TIMING
COMPLIANCE. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. ONE FIFTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI MY NAME IS HEATHER
MARTINEZ I'M FROM INGLEWOOD
CALIFORNIA PRESIDENT OF YOU
KNOW FORTY SIX CULVER CITY AND
I SERIOUSLY OPPOSED THIS BILL
AS AMENDED. THANK YOU. LINE ONE
TENURE LINE IS OPEN. ONE ONE
OPEN. RIGHT BERMAN YARON LESION
AUXILIARY CALIFORNIA GIRL ST
NUMBER ONE FROM NINETEEN NINETY
THREE AND ALTHOUGH I SUPPORT
THIS BILL AYE OPPOSED THE BILL
CURRENTLY WRITTEN AND I ALSO
TAKE ISSUE WITH THE TRAINING AS
WELL NOT VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
ONE TWENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS MAUREEN
O'BRIEN THATGO A MEMBER OF THE
AMERICAN LEGION AUXILIARY AND
FORMER IRVINE- AND I PULLED THE
BILL AS WRITTEN. THE CORRECT.
THANK YOU. LINE EIGHTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANKS FOR
RIGHT WITH THE AMERICAN LEGION
AUXILIARY AND I'M SUPPOSED TO
DEAL ACCURATE. THANK YOU. LINE
TWENTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
LINE TWENTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. YOUR LINE IS MY NAME
RUNNING INTO YOUR. HELLO GO
AHEAD SIR HELLO YES YOU'RE ON.
MY NAME IS DEBBIE MORADO AND I
AND THEN AMERICAN LEGION
AUXILIARY MEMBER AYE OPPOSED
THE BILL IS WRITTEN BECAUSE OF
THE SPECIFIC PREFERENCE I'M
SORRY THANK YOU VERY MUCH. LINE
ONE FIFTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO MY NAME IS BETTY FLORIO
AND THE TWENTY SIXTEEN
CALIFORNIA GIRL HELLO NINE. THE
BILL HAS CURRENTLY RIGHT IN
THANK YOUNG THANK YOU. ONE
SIXTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO MY NAME IS JANET NOR
CONTACT FROM DISTRICT TWELVE I
AM A VOLUNTEER PLEASE KEEP IN
MIND WE ARE ALL VOLUNTEERS. I
OPPOSE THIS BILL AS CURRENTLY
WRITTEN THANK YOU. LINE SIXTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. NAME
IS RANDOLPH MORE IN RELIGION
THERE FOR TWENTY YEARS AND AYE
OPPOSED ISRAEL CARBURETORS NON
LEGISLATIVE SANGER MANDATE ON
THANK YOU SIR. NEXT IN LINE
SIXTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MY
NAME IS KATHY MARTINEZ
PRESIDENT AMERICAN LEGION
AUXILIARY DEPARTMENT OF
CALIFORNIA AND I SINCERELY
APOLOGISES AS WRITTEN WITH
SPECIFIC REFERENCE TO THE
NINETEEN CONCERT ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU THANK YOU. LINE
THIRTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
NINE THIRTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. AND IF YOUR MIND IS MUTED
WERE UNABLE TO HEAR YOU. THIRTY
FIVE YES SIR. YES RANDY REED
LEGIONNAIRE FROM DANVILLE
CALIFORNIA I'M IN OPPOSITION-
BECAUSE THIS BILL WILL REDUCE
OPPORTUNITY VERY MUCH SIR ALL
RIGHT NEXT. LINE FORTY ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. LINE FOUR ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YOUR LINE IS
NEEDED WERE UNABLE TO HEAR YOU.
WHAT NOT RESPONSIBLE BOTTOM
LINE NUMBER ONE NINETEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS
MONEY GETTING AND I AM A
CALIFORNIA GIRL STILL ENOUGH
FROM NINETEEN NINETY SEVEN AND
I OPPOSE THIS BILL AS CURRENTLY
WRITTEN. THANK YOU. LINE FORTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO
THIS IS DANTE BROWN PARK PAST
NATIONAL PRESIDENT AMERICAN
LEGION AUXILIARY I OPPOSE THIS
BILL IS WRITTEN WITH SPECIFIC
REFERENCE I THINK. LINE NUMBER
TWENTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO MY NAME IS AUDREY JAMES
AND I AM. THE LEADING CANDIDATE
FOR DEPARTMENT COMMANDER OF THE
AMERICAN LEGION AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL BECAUSE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH SIR. LINE FIFTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME
IS THAT HILLER. THE CALIFORNIA
BROKE THE BOND HERE- HIGH
CULPABILITY WRITTEN WITH THE
PICTOGRAPHIC THAT IDEAS THANK
YOU MA'AM NEXT PLEASE. ONE ONE
FOURTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO MY NAME IS SAMANTHA
PATRICK I AM IN LA CALIFORNIA
GIRL SAY- I'M NOTHING TWO
THOUSAND TIMES AND A BOY SCOUT
LEADER AND I OPPOSE THAT. THANK
YOU. ONE THIRTY SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. YES JAMES BURTON I AM
THE DISTRICT COMMANDER
DISTRICTS. SIX- SORRY AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU
SEVEN ZERO SEVEN PLEASE. ONE
ONE TWENTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
YES GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS
MARKETING HER NUMBER MY NUMBER
OF THE SONS OF THE AMERICAN
LEGION- AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL
AS WRITTEN WITH SPECIFIC HAPPEN
VERY MUCH SIR. NEXT PLEASE.
LINE ONE TWENTY FOR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS
MAGGIE HEARN I'M AN ALIEN
CALIFORNIA GIRL ALUMNI FROM TWO
THOUSAND FIVE ALTHOUGH I
SUPPORT THE THIRD THE BILL AYE
OPPOSED THE BILL CURRENTLY
AMENDED THANK YOU. AT ONE ONE
TWENTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO MY NAME IS TAMMY PALAZZO
IN THE SEVENTEEN SEVENTEEN YEAR
MEMBER AND DIRECTOR OF A ONLY
GIRL STATE AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL AS WRITTEN AGAIN. THANK
YOU FOR THE TIME CONCERNS. LINE
THIRTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN YES
MY NAME IS DONNA HARPER I AM
CHAIR AT THE LEGISLATIVE
COMMISSION FROM AMERICAN LEGION
CALIFORNIA HERE. WE OPPOSED THE
BILL THANK YOU VERY MUCH SIR.
LINE EIGHTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI THIS IS TONY ROAD
BALLING WITH CAPITOL RESOURCE
INSTITUTE IN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU. BEFORE WE OPEN MY TWENTY
TWO OF THE REMINDER LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU'RE OPPOSITION
OF SB THREE SIX THREE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. LINE TWENTY TWO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. BY TWENTY TO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. MUTED OR UNABLE TO
HEAR YOU. MOVE ON TO MY NUMBER
ONE THIRTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. YEAH MY NAME IS KATHLEEN
CALLED HER ON TRUMP'S BILL
MAHER CALIFORNIA AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL AS AMENDED THANK YOU.
ONE FORTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
RIGHT FORTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. YOUR MIND IS NEEDED WERE
UNABLE TO HEAR YOU. MOVE ON TO
MY NUMBER ONE EIGHTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS
AVAILABLE YEAH AND THAT'S ALL
PART OF THE UNITED FARM YEAH
LIABILITIES BEING OUT THE
CONNECTIVITY THANK YOU. WE HAVE
NO ONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NOW
LET'S BRING IT BACK TO THE
CHAMBER I SEE KNOWN MICROPHONES
UP. SURVEILLANCE CENTER WINNER.
OUR THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN I
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THIS- THE ONLY THING
THAT WAS ACTUALLY- AN INTERN IN
MY OFFICE WHEN SHE RAISES ISSUE
AND SHE WAS ABLE TO CONNECT
WITH A VENN CHAIR OF THE
WOMEN'S CAUCUS AND- THE REST IS
HISTORY AND I'M PROUD TO CO
AUTHOR OF THIS BILL- THIS IS-
IT WAS ON A SHOCKING TO ME.
WHEN I GUESS I SHOULDN'T HAVE
BEEN SHOCKED GIVEN THE HUGE
GENDER INEQUITIES AND SOCIETY
AND THE WORLD- BUT I EVEN SO I
WAS JUST. SURPRISED THAT. THE
DISPARITY CARE SERVICES LONG
OVERDUE I'M SURE FOR THE TIMING
ISSUES WILL GET WORKED OUT-
AND- I'M HAPPY TO MOVE THIS
BILL. THANK YOU SIR WIENER ALL
RIGHT- SO LEYVA A FEW PERSONAL
COMMENTS AS A- LIFE MEMBER OF
AMERICAN LEGION THE SPOUSE OF A
MEMBER OF AMERICAN LEGION THE
FATHER OF A FEMALE VETERAN. I
GOT IT THANK YOU ALSO FOR
EDUCATING ME I'M NOT ABOUT BOYS
STATE AND GIRLS STATE FOR A
VERY LONG PERIOD OF TIME THERE
COULD BE NOTHING MORE IMPORTANT
AS ILLUSTRATED BY THE LAST FOUR
FIVE YEARS AMERICAN POLITICS IT
CIVICS EDUCATION. IS ABSOLUTELY
PARAMOUNT AND I WAS UNAWARE OF
THE GROSS DISPARITY BETWEEN
BOYS AND GIRLS IN THIS CONTEXT
AND SO I REALLY AM GRATEFUL FOR
YOU TO BRING THIS FORWARD I
KNOW THAT THE OPPOSITION USED
WORDS LIKE SUBSTANTIALLY
SIMILAR PROCESS WHICH LAWYERS
MAY RECOGNIZE FROM OF- EARLIER
CASE. OF THE- YES CENTURY IT
SOUNDS IT RINGS OF PLESSY
VERSUS FERGUSON AND SOUL I AM
GRATEFUL FOR YOU BRING THIS
FORWARD I LOOK FORWARD TO.
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH YOU AND I
KNOW YOU'VE BEEN QUITE FLEXIBLE
SO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE-
CENTER WIENER MOVES- MADAM-
CHIEF COUNSEL PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALL YOU NEED TO CLOSE I'M
SORRY. THANK YOU SO MUCH CENTER
I'M BURGER PRECIADO THANK YOU
SENATOR WIENER WHO IS BEEN
SUPPORTED FROM DAY ONE AND A CO
AUTHOR I APPRECIATE BOTH OF YOU
GREATLY. WE TWO WERE SHOCKED
WHEN WE HEARD ABOUT THIS AND
EVEN MORE SHOCKED BY HOW MUCH
OPPOSITION THERE HAS BEEN TO
THIS BILL- WHEN I PRESENTED
EDUCATION COMMITTEE I SAID IT
JUST GOES TO SHOW WHAT A SEXIST
SOCIETY. THAT WE TRULY LIVE IN-
TO MISTER ABU DARA WHEN YOU
HAVE ALL THESE AMENDMENTS WE'D
TALK TO YOU ABOUT THESE
AMENDMENTS SHE SAID YOU'RE OKAY
WITH THEM. AND LESS THAN TWENTY
FOUR HOURS AGO YOU SENT US AN
EMAIL ASKING US TO CONSIDER
CHANGING THE DATE OUR RESPONSES
WE WOULD LOOK AT THAT SO TO
HAVE EVERYONE CALL IN
OPPOSITION. IS JUST SURPRISING
TO ME SO IT'S GOOD TO BE A
LITTLE SURPRISED I SUPPOSE BUT
I WOULD JUST SAY. THAT MORE
THAN FORTY FOUR HUNDRED MEN
HAVE SERVED IN THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATURE. ONE HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY ONE WOMEN HAVE SERVED
IN TE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE I
WOULD ARGUE THAT IF BOYS STATE
AND GIRLS STATE HAD BEEN MORE
EQUITABLE. BACK IN THE DAY MORE
YOUNG WOMEN WOULD HAVE BEEN
EXPOSED TO THEIR GOVERNMENT.
AND WOULD HAVE HAD AN
OPPORTUNITY TO RUN FOR OFFICE.
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR YOUR
POSITIVE COMMENTS MISTER CHAIR
SENATOR WIENER RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU MEANT TO CANCEL THE
CALL THE ROLL. THIS IS ASKS P.
THREE SIX THREE BY SENATOR
LEYVA WITH THE MOTION BY
SENATOR WIENER AT THE MOTION IS
DUE PASSED AS AMENDED AMBERG.
AMBERG. BY BOARD YES. CABALLERO
I HAVE A AT ALL I DID ALSO.
GONZALEZ HERTZBERG AYE
HERTZBERG I'D JONES. JONES NOT
VOTING LAYARD ARE LAYERED I
STERN. STERN AYE STERN AYE
WIECKOWSKI HI MY CASKEY AYE
WIENER AYE WIENER AYE YOU HAVE.
YOU HAVE SEVEN ZERO RIGHT NOW.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THANK
YOU MEMBERS WILL PUT THIS BILL
ON CALL ALL RIGHT CENTER
CORTESE AS HE SAID CORTESE.
CENTER CORTESE HAS SB. SIX FOUR
NINE. ONE SECOND WHILE WE CLEAN
THE PODIUM. SECRETASE YOU
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
COLLEAGUES- GOOD- GOOD
PRESENT SB SIX FORTY NINE A
BILL THAT ALIGNS TENANT
PREFERENCES WITH INTERNAL
REVENUE CODE REQUIREMENTS TO
ALLOW HOUSING DEVELOPMENTS THAT
USE TAX CREDIT OR BOND
FINANCING TO REDUCE
DISPLACEMENT BY USING TENER
PREFERENCES. COBA NINETEEN HAS
FURTHER AMPLIFIED THE
DISPLACEMENT PRESSURES
EXPERIENCED BY CALIFORNIA'S
MOST VULNERABLE POPULATIONS
REDUCED INCOMES AND RISING
HOUSING COSTS. DISPLACEMENT
BECAUSE LOWER INCOME RESIDENTS
WERE DISPROPORTIONATELY PEOPLE
OF COLOR REAL TANGIBLE ISSUES
INCLUDING MENTAL AND PHYSICAL
HEALTH PROBLEMS AN EDUCATIONAL
DEFICIENCIES. DISPLACEMENT
PRESSURES ALSO CALLED SYSTEMS
ARE NEIGHBORS. RECENT STUDY IN
SANTA CLARA COUNTY SHOW THAT
OVER HALF OF DISPOSABLE INCOME
RESIDENTS HAD TO LEAVE THEIR
COMMUNITIES ENTIRELY. LOCAL
TENER PREFERENCES OR CRITICAL
TO MANY CITIES HAVE USED TO
HELP STABILIZE NEIGHBORHOODS
AND PRIORITIZE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING FOR LOCAL RESIDENTS AT
RISK OF DISPLACEMENT. HOWEVER
LOCAL TENANT PREFERENCES
CURRENTLY LACK THE STATEWIDE
LEGISLATIVE SUPPORT NECESSARY
FOR CITIES AND COUNTIES TO
COFFIN AND WE USE THEM IN
AFFORDABLE HOUSING DEVELOPMENTS
FUNDED WITH TAX CREDITS AND
BOND FINANCING. SB SIX FORTY
NINE CREATES A STATE POLICY
THAT SUPPORTS. HOUSING FOR
POPULATIONS AT HIGH RISK PRISON
DISPLACEMENT THAT CITIES AND
COUNTIES CAN USE TENER PURPOSES
AND AFFORDABLE HOUSING
DEVELOPMENTS TO PROTECT THOSE
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS. THESE
CHANGES WILL HELP US TARGET THE
BENEFITS OF SCARCE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING LIMIT DISPLACEMENT IT-REDUCE THE MANY HARMS THAT
RESULT FROM DISPLACEMENT. THE
USE OF LOCAL TENET PURPOSES CAN
ALSO HELP REDUCE OPPOSITION. TO
AFFORDABLE HOUSING DEVELOPMENT
ENHANCE PREDICTABILITY OF
DEVELOPMENT. I WANT TO
EMPHASIZE THAT THIS LEGISLATION
COMPLIMENTS STATE AND FEDERAL
FAIR HOUSING LAW BY SUPPORTING
LOCAL POLICIES AND PROGRAMS TO
FOSTER DIVERSITY AND HOUSING
CHOICE. HERE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF REAL HERNANDEZ. FROM-SO MOST MAJOR IN THE SAN JOSE
AREA YEAH CHRIS ALEXANDER FROM
THE CITY OF SAN JOSE THANK YOU
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL.
THANK YOU CENTER CORTESE
GOVERNOR ALL AND THEN THOSE ARE
YOU AVAILABLE. YES CAN YOU HEAR
ME OK GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
SENATORS MY NAME IS DEBBIE
ALEXANDER'S I GREW UP IN THE
SITE SAN JOSE AND I'M CURRENTLY
WORKING AS A COMMUNITY
ADVOCATES FOR SOME MOSTLY FAIR
ORGANIZING WITH LOW INCOME AND
MARGINALIZED FAMILIES
ADDRESSING HOUSING ISSUES LIKE
GENTRIFICATION AND
DISPLACEMENT. HISTORICALLY OUR
FAMILY SHOULD LIVE IN AREAS
ASSEMBLY THAT HAVE BEEN READ
LINE. BY THE BANKING AND REAL
ESTATE INDUSTRIES. PASSWORD
ONLY DONE TO IN THE LOCAL
INFRASTRUCTURE OF OUR
NEIGHBORHOODS. AND WE WERE LEFT
IN THE BALLPARK ROOM SOCIAL
MUTUAL AID NETWORKS ALMOST OUR
FAMILIES. AT ONE OF OUR
FAMILIES ARE IN WITH RESTORING
THROUGH THE ROOF WE ARE
EXPERIENCING A KIND OF SUPPORT
FAMILIES IN OUR NEIGHBORHOODS.
OVER THE PAST SEVERAL YEARS
WE'VE WORKED WITH THE CITY OF
SEVERAL DAYS HOUSING
DEPARTMENT. TO DEVELOP MANY
STRATEGIES TO SALUTE THE
DISPLACEMENT OF OUR FAMILY. WE
HAVE DEVELOPED AN ANTI
DISPLACEMENT LOOK WHAT KIND OF
PENSIONS POLICIES THAT WE HOPE
WILL KEEP OUR FAMILIES AND
SALAS NE. WE ARE ASKING THE
STATE OF SUPPORT OUR EFFORTS BY
ADOPTING SD SIX FORTY NINE.
THAT WILL ALLOW INTERNET
PREFERENCES WITH. THE INTERNAL
REVENUE CODE RETIREMENT SO WILL
QUALIFY AFFORDABLE HOUSING
DEVELOPMENTS. FOR TAX CREDITS
AND BOND FINANCING. ONE OF OUR
LEADERS IN THE SELECT SOME MUCH
CHILDREN AND HAS MOVED THAN TEN
TIMES AND LAST YEARS. YOU'RE
TRYING TO STAY IN THE MAY THIRD
DISTRICT IN SOME OF THE-
CHEAPER CHILDREN THE HOME. I'M
NOT ONE OF OUR MONEY IF THAT IS.
HAS LIVED IN SOME OF THE FOR
MORE TWENTY YEARS AND HAD TO
MOVE SIXTEEN SOUTH OF SAN THE
BIG OF THE RENT HIKES. SHE
FOUND AN OPPORTUNITY TO RETURN
BETTER LIVING CONDITIONS WHILE
INCLUDE LIVING WITH TWO OTHER
FAMILIES IN THE HOUSE. PLEASE
NOTICE WHICH- COULD. AS WE
FIGHT TO HER FROM. AND SOME OF
THE- AND THERE ARE SO. NETWORK
WE SUPPORT S. B. C. FORTY NINE.
THANK YOU SENATOR. FOR THIS
BILL. THANK YOU. THANK YOU MR
ANAND. BOB CHRIS ALEXANDER YOU
BUILD. YES I CAN YOU ME YES WE
CAN AHEAD. THANK YOU CARE ABOUT
HER AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS THIS
IS CHRIS ALEXANDER FOR THE CITY
OF SAN JOSE. THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TODAY AS A
WITNESS IN SUPPORT OF SENATE
BILL SIX FORTY NINE LOCAL KIND
OF PREFERENCE TO PREVENT
DISPLACEMENT TAX. LOCAL KIND OF
PREFERENCES HELP PRIORITIZE
SCARCE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
RESOURCES TO HELP STABILISE
HOUSING FOR LOWER INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS. TO REDUCE THE
DISPLACEMENT AND ITS
CONCOMITANT IMPACTS LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS ACROSS THE COUNTRY
HAVE ADOPTED LOCAL HOUSING
PREFERENCES HELP KEEP PEOPLE
FROM BEING UPROOTED FROM THEIR
HOMES FAMILIES AND NETWORKS.
HERE IN CALIFORNIA SB SIX FORTY
NINE WILL PLAY A VITAL ROLE IN
BOLSTERING THE STATE'S EFFORTS
TO PROTECT OUR MOST. VULNERABLE
RESIDENTS FROM DISPLACEMENT.
MOST AFFORDABLE HOUSING HELP IS.
IN PART BY FEDERAL AND WILLING
HOUSING TAX CREDITS. UNDER
FEDERAL LAW AN ELIGIBLE PROJECT
MUST GENERALLY BE DEDICATED TO
A PUBLIC USE. BUT PREFERENCES
ARE PERMITTED FOR AMONG OTHERS
TENANTS WERE MEMBERS OF A
SPECIFIED GROUP UNDER A STATE
PROGRAM OR POLICY THAT SUPPORTS
HOUSING FOR THE- GROUP. THE
CALIFORNIA HOUSING CONSORTIUM
WHICH SUPPORTS THIS BILL RIGHT
THAT THE LEGISLATURE NEEDS TO
MAKE COLLEGE DEFINING TO ALLOW
FOR THE USE OF TENET
PREFERENCES. IN FEDERAL TAX
CREDIT AND BOND FUNDED PROJECTS
TO SUPPORT THE USE OF STATE
FUNDING IN THESE DEVELOPMENTS.
INDEED THIS BILL CREATES. A
POLICY SUPPORTING LOCAL
TELECONFERENCES IN AFFORDABLE
HOUSING FOR LOWER INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS. THAT ARE SUBJECT TO
DISPLACEMENT RISK. THIS BILL IS
MODELED AFTER THE TEACHER
HOUSING ACT TWENTY SIXTEEN THAT
ALSO CREATED A STATE POLICY
SUPPORTING THE USE OF FEDERAL
AND STATE LOW INCOME HOUSING
TAX CREDIT. ON HOUSING FOR
TEACHERS AND SCHOOL DISTRICT
EMPLOYEES ON LAND OWNED BY THE
SCHOOL DISTRICT. OF COURSE
CITIES MUST BE COGNISANT OF THE
HISTORICAL AND LEGAL FRAMEWORK.
CRAFTING AFFORDABLE HOUSING
PREFERENCE POLICIES TO ENSURE
THAT THEY ARE COMPLYING WITH-
HOUSING LAWS. THE LADY OF A
LOCAL RESIDENT YOU PREFERENCE
THE CASE BY CASE DETERMINATION
DEPENDS ON SUCH FACTORS OF TH
COMPOSITION OF THE COMMUNITY.
AND SURROUNDING COMMUNITIES
WHOSE EXCLUSION MIGHT HAVE THE
CONSEQUENCES OF PERPETUATING
HISTORICAL INEQUITY.
RECOGNIZING THESE IMPORTANT
CONSIDERATIONS THE BILL.
REQUIRES LOCAL GOVERNMENTS.
THANK YOU SIR. ALL RIGHT LET'S
TURN TO OTHERS IN SUPPORT. IN
THE GALLERY ANYONE ELSE IN THE
GALLERY NO ONE IN THE GALLERY
ROOM ONE TWELVE NO ONE IN ROOM
ONE TWELVE TESTIFYING IN
SUPPORT. THAT'S BECAUSE THE
PHONE LINES. MODERATOR IF YOU
TWO OF THOSE IN SUPPORT OF SB
SIX FOUR NINE. CERTAINLY LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB SIX FOUR
NINE YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO ACTIVE TIME. AND CURRENTLY
WE HAVE THREE IN Q. ALREADY.
WE'LL START WITH ONE FIFTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THE FUTURE
MEMBERS ELOQUENTLY STRATEGY
THREE FIFTY ON BEHALF OF THE
HOUSING ACTION COALITION HOW
COSPONSORED THE MEASURE IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. ONE ONE
THIRTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MEMBERS RANDY MARTIN ON BEHALF
OF THE AIDS HEALTHCARE
FOUNDATION AND IT'S HEALTHY
HOUSING FOUNDATION IN IN
SUPPORT OF THIS VERY IMPACTFUL
BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU. AND
BEFORE WE OPEN LINE ONE THIRTY
EIGHT AS A REMINDER LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO BE
RECORDED SB SIX FOUR NINE YOU
MAY PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. LINE ONE THIRTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ONE ONE
THIRTY EIGHT YOU REMOVE
YOURSELF FROM QUEUE IF YOU LIKE
IT'S BECAUSE THE COURT YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AT ZERO OPEN UP YOUR
LINE. AND AT THIS TIME SO NO
ONE ELSE OKAY. ONE ONE THIRTY
EIGHT YOUR MIND OPEN. THANK
YOU. MR CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS.
MICHAEL RAT AGAIN ON BEHALF OF
THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS OF
SANTA CLARA COUNTY IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
FOR AT THE TIME I SHOW NO ONE
ELSE IN SUPPORT RT THANK YOU-
LET'S NOT. TURNED OPPOSITION I
SEE NO. WITNESSES LISTED AS
PRINCIPAL WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. IS NOW IN THE
GALLERY NO ONE IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE. MEMORY IS THERE ANYONE
ON THE PHONE LINE WE SHOULD
TESTIFY AS THE PRINCIPAL
OPPONENT TO S. B. SIX FOUR
NINE. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
OF SB SIX FOUR NINE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THE TIME. AND
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF SB SIX FOUR
NINE YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THE TIME. WHEN I SHOW NO ONE IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. OKAY
LET'S BRING IT BACK TO THE
CHAMBER. SENATE LAYERED BILL
MILLER MOVES A BILL ANY OTHER
DISCUSSION SEEING NO OTHER
MICROPHONES RAISED CENTER
CORTESE TO CLOSE RESPECTFULLY
ASK RIVAL THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU SENATOR A MAN CHIEF
COUNSEL ESTADO IF YOU CALL THE
ROLL YES THIS IS THE S. B. S.
SIX FOUR NINE BY CENTER
CORTESE- BY AND WITH THE MOTION
BY SENATOR LAYERED THE MOTION
IS TO PASS- BURKE HI AMBER GUY
BURGESS. GORGEOUS I GOT. I HAVE
A ALL I DID US. GONZALEZ
GONZALEZ I HEARD. HERTZBERG AYE
JONES HI JONES I LIVE ON
LAYERED I. WALL STERN I HOUSE
HI WHITE HOUSE I. WIENER YOU
HAVE TEN TO SELF WITH A MEMBER
MISSING. ALL RIGHTY WE'LL PUT
THAT BILLING CALL THANK YOU
SENATE CORTESE WE NOW HAVE-
CENTER BRADFORD'S SB SIX FIVE
FIVE THIS IS THE LAST BILL THAT
WILL BE HEARING THIS AFTERNOON.
SO CENTER BRADFORD THE FLOOR IS
YOURS ONCE PODIUM IS HAS BEEN
CLEAN. THANK YOU MR I'M HERE TO
PRESENT SB SIX FIVE FIVE WHICH
IS STRAIGHT AHEAD MEASURE THAT
SIMPLY REESTABLISHES- THE
CALIFORNIA INSURANCE DIVERSITY
SURVEY WHICH WAS CREATED UNDER.
A PREVIOUS PIECE OF LEGISLATION
AUTHORED SB FIVE THREE FOUR. IT
DOES THREE SIMPLE THINGS IT
JUST LOWERS- THE EXISTING
CALIFORNIA PREMIUM REPORTING
THRESHOLD FROM A HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS TO SEVENTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS WHICH ALLOWS US
TO CAPTURE MORE COMPANIES AND I
UNDERSTAND WHAT THE GOVERNING
BOARD AND THEIR SUPPLIER
DIVERSITY DATA LOOKS LIKE. THE
CODIFIES REPORTING REQUIREMENTS
FOR UNDERREPRESENTED GROUPS ON
INSURANCE COMPANY GOVERNING
BOARDS TO INCLUDE REQUIRING
INSURANCE COMPANIES TO PROVIDE
GOVERNING BOARDS DIVERSITY
POLICY STATEMENT OR MEASURABLE
GOALS AND IT DEFINES THE TERM
DIVERSE INVESTMENT MANAGERS AND
THE CORN PROGRAM. AGAIN A
PROGRAM THAT WAS STARTED UNDER
THE PREVIOUS- INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER HAS BEEN EXPANDED
WHAT ARE CURRENT AND FORMER
COLLEAGUE- CURRENT COMMISSIONER
SINGH FORMER COLLEAGUE HERE
THAT ARE CAUGHT A LOT OF- SIX
FIVE FIVE JUST BUILDS UPON THE
SUCCESS- A DATA. PULLED FROM
INSURERS AND ARCHERS THE
IMPLEMENTATION IMMEASURABLE
GOALS TOWARD DIVERSITY AND
INCLUSION INVESTMENTS AND
PRACTICES IT'S SOMETHING THAT
IS WORKED OVER THE NUMBER OF
YEARS OVER THIRTY FIVE YEARS AS
A SAY WITH THERE ARE UTILITY
SPACE WITH SUPPLIER DIVERSITY
THAT WAS STARTED BY THE LATE
ASSEMBLY PERSON GOING MORE AND
WE'RE TRYING TO FALL THAT MODEL
HERE. TO TESTIFY TODAY IN
SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURES
MELISSA GEAR WHO'S THE CHIEF
DEPUTY LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR FOR
OUR INSURANCE COMMISSIONER-
CAUGHT A LOT OF. HEY AND I
RESPECT THAT FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU CENTER BRADFORD. THE
SCARY BILL. I AM THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT GOOD ACTORS GOOD
AFTERNOON THERE AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE HELLO THANK YOU
SHE THAT THE ALLEGED DIRECTOR
HERE ON BEHALF OF INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER RICARDO LARA AND
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE. AB ONE THIRD SB SIX
FIVE FIVE COMMISSIONER LARA
WOULD LIKE TO THANK SENATOR
BRADFORD FOR HIS LEADERSHIP IN
OFFERING THIS IMPORTANT MEASURE
THAT INCREASES EQUITY DIVERSITY
AND TRANSPARENCY ON
CALIFORNIA'S INSURANCE MARKETS.
UNDER THE NEW SEVENTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS REPORTING
THRESHOLD IN THE BILL THERE
WOULD BE A MODEST INCREASE IN
THE NUMBER OF COMPANIES THAT
WOULD BE REQUIRED TO REPORT.
HOWEVER WE ARE COMMITTED TO
PROVIDING THESE COMPANIES WITH-
ANY SUPPORT. AND EVERYTHING
THAT THEY NEED AN ASSISTANT AND
WE'LL BE DOING- COMPREHENSIVE
TRAINING SESSION BY THE
DEPARTMENT STAFF. ALTHOUGH MANY
INSURANCE COMPANIES CURRENTLY
SHARE THEIR GOVERNING BOARD
GOALS AND POLICY STATEMENTS
WITH THE DEPARTMENT TODAY.
SEEKING TO PROVIDE GUIDANCE THE
COMPANY AND TO ASSIST THOSE
COMPANIES THAT HAVE NOT
PROVIDED GOAL OUR STATEMENTS IN
THE PAST. THE BILL PROPOSED
LANGUAGE PROVIDES COMPANIES
WITH SOME FLEXIBILITY REGARDING
WHAT A DIVERSITY POLICY
STATEMENT INTEL IT IS NOT MEANT
TO BE AN EXHAUSTIVE LIST. THE
BOARD DIVERSITY SURVEY AND
RELATED DATA INCLUDING THE
POLICY GOALS AND STATEMENTS ARE
REPORTED TO THE DEPARTMENT
CONFIDENTIALLY. AND THEN
PUBLISHED BY THE DEPARTMENT IN
THE AGGREGATE SO AS NOT TO BE
ABLE TO IDENTIFY ANY COMPANY OR
BOARD MEMBER. COMMISSIONER LARA
AND THE DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE
MAINTAIN AN UNWAVERING
COMMITMENT TO DIVERSITY EQUITY
AND INCLUSION. I BELIEVE THE
COMMUNITIES WE SERVE EXPECT US
TO USE EVERY POSSIBLE TOOL
INCLUDING THE FULL SCOPE OF
DIVERSITY AND INCLUSION OF THE
VERY PEOPLE THAT SIT AND
DECISION MAKING THE- AND THAT
ARE CONTRACTED WITH TO PROVIDE
ESSENTIAL GOODS AND SERVICES.
THANK YOU TO THE COMMITTEE AND
THE STAFF FOR THEIR WORK ON
THIS BILL AND WE LOOK FORWARD
TO CONTINUED COLLABORATION AS
THE BILL MOVES FORWARD IN THE
PROCESS. I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
YOUR FIVE VOTE ON THAT MEASURE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU MISS
GEAR BOB OTHERS IN SUPPORT I
SEE NO IN THE GALLERY I SEE NO
ONE IN ROOM ONE TWELVE. MADAM
MODERATOR IS THERE ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF SB
SIX FIVE FIVE. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF SB SIX FIVE FIVE
YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THE TIME. AND ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB
SIX FIVE FIVE YOU MAYPRESS ONE
BUTTON ZERO. AT THE TIME. AND I
SHOW NO ONE IN SUPPORT. ALL
RIGHT LET'S TURNED OPPOSITION I
SEE NO ONE LISTED AS THE MAIN
OPPONENT OF SB SIX FIVE FIVE- I
SEE NO ONE IN THE GALLERY I SEE
NO ONE IN ROOM ONE TWELVE.
MEMORY IS THERE ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE OPPOSITION TO SB SIX
FIVE FIVE. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF SB SIX BY FIVE
YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AND ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
SB SIX BY FIVE YOU MAY PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THE TIME. AND
I SHOW NO ONE IN OPPOSITION ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
BEFORE WE TURN TO THE CHAMBER
FOR QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. WILL
SOON BE CONCLUDING HERE AND
LIFTING ALL CALLS ALL RIGHT. I
SEE NO MICROPHONES UP. SIR
BRADFORD YOU CARE TO CLOSE WELL
I'M SORRY SERVICES EARLIER ARE
JUST GONNA MOVE THE BILL ALL
RIGHT. GOOD WORK ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU. SIR BRADFORD YOU CAN
CLOSE ON THE QUOTE WHILE I'M
AHEAD AND SIMPLY ASK FOR A
VOTE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
BETTER CHIEF COUNSEL STARTED TO
CALL THE ROLL. YES THIS IS
SENATE BILL SIX FIFTY FIVE BY
SENATOR BRADFORD WITH THE
MOTION BY SENATOR LAYERED THE
MOTION IS. DO PASSED BUT FIRST
BE REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS- BURKE. AMBERG
BY BORJAS. GORGEOUS I GOT IT
ALL HI HAVE YOU HAD A I DID US.
GONZALEZ HI GONZALEZ I
HERTZBERG. JONES JONES I
LAYERED BY LAYERED I STERN.
STERN AYE STERN I WAKE CAL SKI
WHITE HOUSE SKI I WIENER WIENER
AYE YOU HAVE NINE TWO ZERO SO
FAR ALL RIGHT WE'LL PUT THAT
BELONG CALL THAT WAS THE LAST
BILL I GUESS COMMITTEE MEMBERS
TO NOTE THE TIME IT IS THREE
O'CLOCK- DON'T RAISE FALSE
EXPECTATIONS FOR OUR NEXT
COMMITTEE MEETING. ALL RIGHT SO
LET'S LIVECALLS- ON ALL THE
BILLS FOR BILLS FOR FIVE PLUS
CONSENT CALENDAR. HI ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I'D WIENER. AYE WIENER
AYE YAY YOU HAVE ELEVEN TWO
ZERO ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
ALL RIGHT THAT CONSENT COUNTERS
ADOPTED. NEXT WE ARE AT S. B.
THREE THREE TWO DURACELL.
YOU'RE STILL AT TEN TWO ZERO
ALL RIGHT WE'LL PUT IT BACK ON
CALL. NEXT MEASURE SB THREE
SIXTY THREE BY SENATOR LEYVA
WITH THE CHAIR VOTING I'D
GORGEOUS. PORGES NOT VOTING.
THE DOCILE GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I
JONES NOT VOTING. PRIME TIME
YOU GOT EIGHT ZERO WITH
REMEMBER MISSING PUT THAT BACK
ON CALL. C. CENTER HERTZBERG
WHICH IS TO BE RECOGNIZED- OKAY
WE'VE WE RECOGNIZE YOU CENTER
HERTZBERG YOU'VE ALREADY VOTED.
THANK. THE NEXT ONE IS S. B.
SIX FORTY NINE BY SENATOR
CORTEZ SAY- WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I'D DID ASAL. OKAY YOU
STILL HAVE TEN TO ZERO ON THAT
ONE SECOND CALL. ALL RIGHT THE
NEXT ONE IS SB SIX FIFTY FIVE
BY SENATOR BRADFORD WITH THE
CHAIR VOTING I'D ALSO.
HERTZBERG HERTZBERG HI YOU HAVE
TEN TO ZERO ON THAT ONE THING
MISSING MEMBER. WAY BACK ON
CALL- AND SO IF WE COULD FIND
OUT- CENTRED ROSS'S INTENTIONS
IT WILL. WAIT TO ADJOURN HERE
MOMENTARILY.
ALL RIGHT WELL TO
CANCEL AT SCHOOL- OPEN THE
CALLS THANK YOU SENATOR ALSO
THANK OKAY SO WE HAVE S. B.
THIRTY BY SENATOR DODD FOR
DETERMINING I DID ALSO HI DID I
SO I YOU HAVE ELEVEN TWO ZERO
SENATOR BILLS OUT- NEXT BILL WE
HAVE IS SB THREE SIXTY THREE BY
SENATOR LABOR WITH THE
TRAVELING I. DID ALSO DID US-
EYEING HILLS OUT. YOU HAVE.
312-345-6787 NINE TWO ZERO. THE
BILL OUT HELLO THANK YOU. OUR
NEXT ONE SB SIX FORTY NINE BY
CORTES HAND TOUCH HER VOTING I
DID ALSO. IT ALSO I THAT HAS
ELEVEN TO ZERO ALL RIGHT THAT
BILLS ELEVEN ZERO OKAY THANK
YOU AND THEN THE LAST ONE IS SB
SIX FIFTY FIVE BY SENATOR
BRADFORD. WITH THE CHAIR VOTING
I DIDALSO. THE REST SO I
THAT'SELEVEN TWO ZERO. ALREADY
THE BILL'S ELEVEN ZERO THANK
YOU SENATOR RUSSELL. THE
COMMITTEE IS ADJOURNED.